you
all right i think we're going to get
started in just a couple minutes
give everyone a few more minutes to if
anyone else wants to
show up
okay commissioner
we good i'm good all right well good
good morning good morning everyone
thanks for joining us this morning
uh kicking off capital budget hearings
the first meeting of the budget for next
year which is exciting um a lot to do
and a lot to discuss in a variety of
different ways um i guess what i'd first
uh like to do
um should we introduce folks
yeah sure let's
you know i'm just gonna have everyone go
right around the table and at least uh
introduce themselves because i know
there could be questions for various
members that will be coming up and
michelle carraway administrative
sherry rockburn assistant commissioner
department of administrative services
good morning dennis goulet uh
commissioner of the department of
information technology
uh charlie arlingham's commission of
administrative services and i'm doubling
for ted kupper the director of public
works as well so periodically
my name is james gary and i'm the
director of the budget director for the
state of new hampshire and chris sununu
governor
john
senator reagan i'm the chairman of the
capital budget
john graham chairman of public works and
highways in the house which handles the
capital budget
oh sorry hey i'm sorry
crochet legislative budget assistant
office of course thank governor
thank you didn't see you down there um
well thank you i'm going to open things
up with it with just with a few remarks
i think it's important to kind of set
not just where we're going but doing
things there we have very different
dynamics different variables that i
think we're going to have to understand
as we go into the both the capital and
operational budget uh into next year uh
we have uh a tough economy ahead of us
there's no doubt about that and and
that's being polite about it frankly i
believe the first uh group we're going
to hear from this morning the first
agency if you will um is the university
system uh and we can we'll talk a little
bit about that but
i do want to back up and just uh set a
context if you will
for really what's ahead
i think the state has done a phenomenal
job managing our finances there's no
question about that we have one of the
strongest economies in the country we
have beyond record surpluses beyond
revenues that frankly nobody could could
predict or imagine so that gives us a
lot of opportunity but there is a lot of
need out there as well uh every when we
talk about our surplus funds uh we're
talking about having to supplement
energy costs in in the heating oil costs
and offsetting some of the inflationary
costs for individuals these are one-time
funds uh effectively not necessarily
directly out of the rainy day fund but
they could be uh but you allowing the
legislature to use the surplus funds to
help businesses and individuals across
this state is going to be i think a
priority uh between now and at least uh
next year without a doubt
uh so that doesn't necessarily mean that
we have uh gobs and gobs of money just
to throw at capital but i think we have
ample amounts if you will
then you look at what's really happening
uh nationally and what's happening with
credit markets i think that has to take
be taken into very serious consideration
by uh by folks first you have the supply
chain issues we all know about that then
you have the inflationary cost
a lot of what we talk about over the
next couple days with our capital budget
is building bricks and mortar and
infrastructure and that's all very very
important stuff
but you have to understand also that the
costs of doing that are are well beyond
the 8.3 inflationary rate that we see uh
the construction costs are are just
absolutely skyrocketing in some place uh
30 to 100
over typically what we would get for the
same dollar
in a given year
there is competition because of the
supply chain issue so every time we do a
project let's remember that we are
taking supply chain product from other
private companies or other projects
around the state and there's just a
limited amount that's going to be
available you have projects that should
be done in two months that are literally
taking a year we're seeing that across
the country i don't see that uh lifting
anytime soon so we have to consider uh
supply chain issues how we cost things
out how we plan and how we budget what
we don't want to do is get into a
situation where we're creating
engineering design and costs for a
million dollars only to find next year
uh when we when we have to actually pay
the bill that it's a two million dollar
project
and then on top of that you have this
little thing called interest rates uh
the cost of borrowing a dollar right now
is high and it's only going up there's
no two ways about that uh this in this
uh in
inflation that you're seeing is very
real and lord knows i am not the premier
economist but it is very basic math it
is actually very simple math to know
that interest rates have to keep going
higher to outpace inflation to get this
economy back into line and unfortunately
what you're going to see is a stagnated
economy and you are going to see some
form of a recession regardless of what
the nonsense politics out of washington
are everybody knows that some realistic
recession is coming
then we have our arpa funds let's not
forget that when you inject five
trillion dollars into the economy over a
period of two years that's what's
creating the inflationary issue but a
lot of that has come out in terms of
infrastructure so we do have our
infrastructure bill which primarily goes
to the roads bridges broadband waterways
about a trillion dollars was authorized
by the federal government about a year
ago
most of the i don't think a single penny
of that money has actually really been
spent yet the first dollars are just
being released into broadband new
hampshire's doing a phenomenal job with
that um we're going to be the first
state in the country that invests in our
expanded broadband here uh through the
arpa funds which is great being first at
the trough means that you you're
more likely to have the supply actually
have the product i actually have the
labor force to put it in the ground and
that's that's phenomenal and i really
commend the folks at bea for for making
sure we were number one in the country
on that
but uh
what you really also under have to
understand is we already have a lot of
money coming in for for buildings for
bridges for roads for all of these
pieces and so that definitely has to be
taken into account there's already a lot
of infrastructure development going on
uh to to walk kind of parallel path with
the capital budget that we're talking
about today
um
so
where it ends up
i think i i'm not i don't want to put
anything in stone as to exactly what
i'll be proposing next february but one
thing to consider and i think we should
hear about all the projects but i've
gone back to all the different agencies
and typically you know they'll come in
and we'll see a presentation of 40 plus
agencies uh and you could see anywhere
from
400 to 800 million dollars in projects
that is not reality that is not going to
happen uh we're likely uh going the
state is going to look at authorizing
this expenditure of 125 million should
that all be bonded i personally don't
think so we can we'll have that debate
and we'll find out where those funds
come from but the reality is i think
we'll have surplus funds to use cash to
minimize the bonding capacity that we
otherwise would use because the interest
rate alone on this money will be
astronomical if we're not smart about
how we do it so by creating a strong
economy by being smart with our surplus
revenues that's going to give us the
opportunity to still invest in these
projects but a lot of it with our own
cash at
effectively zero percent interest and
that's a good thing
we'll still i think should go out and
borrow i think the markets are still
will be fairly healthy but at the same
time we have to be smart about where we
go
we still have some very large projects i
don't want to go into too much but i'll
let the departments talk about but
there's two specific uh
uh projects i want to talk about one is
the men's state prison
this project has to be done at some
point probably not in the next couple
years
uh we're not prepared for that we but i
think in the next five to ten years you
are looking at a 350 to 500 million
dollar investment that this state will
have to make in the men's state prison
um that's a reality uh i don't i've
talked to commissioner hanks and she
agrees uh oh commissioner you are here
how are you well i don't want to speak
for the commissioner but uh we talked
about the need for this project it has
to happen but we have to be prepared uh
so i think uh i mean she'll talk about
the project and i've asked her to talk
about it in a little more detail
about where we go but the first step is
really making sure we get a feasibility
study some of the preliminary
engineering a realistic cost estimate
because what we really want to do is
make sure the legislature has all the
data and all the information possible so
i'm not proposing moving forward with a
350 million dollar new prison because i
don't think we're prepared for that and
i think borrowing that kind of money at
this point would be um would be foolish
frankly um so there could be a cooling
of the markets in a couple years and
there could be a better time to do it
and a smarter time to do it as we come
down the road but i do want the
legislature to start having that
discussion now and taking that
information in understanding where we
need to go and really making sure that
we're thinking about the future
the second one of the second projects i
just want to talk about is is with the
university system and we're going to
bring them up in a moment to talk about
some of their needs and projects but we
made a commitment or at least i made and
the legislature made a commitment a
couple budget cycles ago to really make
sure that the state was partnering and
investing in uh in a variety of
different projects the keene state
project plymouth state and the life
sciences project over at unh those
projects have
have been ongoing
some of them i guess are just starting
but the unh project has been ongoing
it's a multi-phase project over the next
few years going to provide an immense
opportunity to allow the university
system to really come in line with where
a lot of our direct workforce needs are
going to be whether it's in biolife
sciences regenerative medicine all of
those sorts of things and create
opportunities for those students that
can then stay here work here really
building our workforce i really do see
it as an investment in new hampshire's
future workforce uh and and uh so again
i'll be very supportive um and and of
making sure that we fulfill on that
obligation we've done it in a couple
different phases but fulfilling uh on
that obligation as well
um we we made a huge investment with the
nursing school a couple years ago and
boy i mean that's already paying
dividends uh if there was ever a time to
you know prepare for the oncoming need
of nurses uh in health care workforce we
we did that in the legislature um i did
that a few years ago and and we've
effectively doubled the number of nurses
uh the opportunity for the number of
nurses to come out of unh as our ends
and retain them right here in new
hampshire so those investments really do
work um they're they're not just well it
sounds like a good idea let's see how it
pans out this is really an investment
that is a
addressing a direct need of the state
today and without a doubt a growing need
that's going to be there uh in the
future so again i i think that
just to understand where markets are
going where interest rates are going
um i think we have the ability to still
spend 125 million that's what i'll be
recommending to the legislature but how
we parse that out i think will be a
little bit different i think we just
need to be smarter about not just saying
well we're going to borrow 125 million
on a very inflated interest rate market
that might only be growing
in the coming years
and also remember you know not to get
too technical but when we authorize the
funding when we sign that capital budget
next june that doesn't mean we borrow
the money the next day right sometimes
we borrow the money six
six months a year even 18 months down
the road because we have to time it to
the projects as they come to fruition so
the unknown escalation of that interest
rate market is something else that the
legislature will really have to consider
and hopefully as we go through the
process between now and february and all
through next spring we'll all have a
better sense of of where this is where
this economy is really playing out and
where that that market plays out and
then i think we can really have a
more deeper discussion about where the
dollars come from but we're in good
shape here there's no doubt about it new
hampshire's in good shape to make these
investments one way or the other um
we're just going to make sure that we're
looking at prioritizing the last thing
i'm going to i want to mention really
quick uh again i got to back up to a
point i brought up earlier typically
we'll see 500 million or even 900
million dollars of projects come before
this group in a combination of general
funds and
and uh federal funds other money highway
funds i've really asked the departments
to cut that back because let's get let's
make sure we're focusing on priorities i
don't want to over tax admin
administrative services having to review
and check 900 billion dollars of
projects when we know we're looking at
about if you add in all the highway and
other money and federal money that might
come in maybe 300 million dollars a
project something like that maybe 150 to
300 million so i've really asked the
agencies to to cut back what their
requests are what their presentations
are so that the legislature can and
admin services and our teams can really
focus on the highest needs the highest
priorities and just be much more
efficient i think as we go through the
the entire process
um okay with that i think we'll we'll
open it up to uh and i'll i'm gonna just
for uh
for everyone's
the fyi is i'll be here for the first
presentation uh with the university
system and then i do have to step out
for other meetings uh james gary will be
here our new budget director uh within
my office james comes from the
department of revenue administration and
when it comes to financial stuff he's
wicked smart as we say here in new
hampshire
so with that we'll kick it off with the
good morning governor and
members of the committee this morning my
name is kathy provencher i serve as the
chief administrative officer and vice
chancellor of finance for our state's
university system
glad to be here this morning president
jim dean of unh and current interim
chancellor sends his regrets he is
traveling back to new hampshire today
from a long planned vacation um he would
have been here
were it not for that there is material
we've i've put together a handful of
slides i'm not going to walk through all
of these slides i just want to hit some
high points
so
as the governor mentioned during his
opening remarks on slide 2 back in 2019
the capital budget that was
adopted provided for three biennium of
capital
funds for
university system projects fiscal years
24 and 25 is that third biennium and we
that stay intact
we aren't asking for anything more
obviously but ask that that stay in tax
i'll talk in a minute about back in 2019
the university system committed
that any overages the university system
would cover we weren't going to come
back to the state for additional funds
and so for 2 fiscal years 24 and 25 at
you can see on slide four
in the shaded column
the 17 million dollars
will be allocated to the biological
sciences
initiative at unh i'll talk in a bit
about that
hyde hall at plymouth state and elliott
and joslin halls at keene state just as
outlined in the 19 2019 capital budget
law
on slide five
i just want to give
an an
overall look of where the funding comes
from for the university systems capital
program
we generally target to spend
one times depreciation
every year on our capital total capital
program so we're doing the best we can
to keep up with deferred maintenance
so we've spent over the past six years
we've spent
447 million dollars on our capital
program
the vast majority of that from
university system funds the state funds
help enormously in in our overall
capital program our new debt
has amounted to about seven percent and
just um for folks information
the university system is authorized by
law to issue debt for what we call
self-supporting
structures
res halls dining halls we do not have
statutory authority and do not borrow or
issue debt for academic buildings and
that's why the programs that
the projects that
we've requested state funds for are
solely academic programs
on um slide seven it's the
status if you will of where we are on
the unh biological sciences initiative
this project will eliminate about 30
million dollars in deferred maintenance
it's a complete renovation of spaulding
hall which is i think was built in the
70s and in addition
um
we're we're putting an addition on to
spalding hall
with the renovation
the um
let me just it's a 95 million dollar
project it's the largest project the
university system has ever undertaken
the state has supported 35 million of
that project in the university system
is funding the other 60 million
on slide nine
you can see where we are in the
different phases
we've completed phase one that was the
renovation it was completed in april
faculty and staff are already occupying
that space and phase two began this
month and of note we have a guaranteed
maximum price that was signed off in
january of 21 so we know what the price
of the project is
i'd also offer if anyone's ever
interested in taking a tour of the
facility
always happy to arrange that if folks
wanted to come over and and see where
the dollars are going
the um i'm now going to just skip
quickly in the interest of time
slide 13 hyde hall at plymouth state
university
this project will eliminate 17 million
dollars in deferred maintenance hyde
hall is the most used academic space on
the plymouth state campus
and the business program is in that
facility
and so that it's one of our top needs at
plymouth state
that project we're well into planning
construction has not yet begun and then
at keene state on slide 17
elliott hall and joslin hall again
a lot of deferred maintenance needs in
those in those buildings
the vision here is to
turn elliot hall into a student success
center so you have one-stop shopping
from admissions to graduation for
retention issues
and career services everything in one
space for our students
i
went through that quickly but in the
interest of time i wanted to make sure
that we provide i provided you with
enough time to ask questions and as
always if you ever have any follow-up
questions or slide at the very end has
my contact as well as tom cronin's
thomas with me this morning he's the
director of government relations and you
can reach out anytime with follow-up
questions
great thank you i appreciate that we'll
thank you governor
kathy um
we've been around this block several
times
you're not going to come in and ask for
anything more for this next biennium or
i just want you to talk a little bit
about the
competitive status of unh and how these
projects may help
to
add to your competitive status in
attracting students in this environment
that we're in today thank you for the
question um
this biological sciences initiative is
an imperative
to ensure that we remain competitive
especially with flagships around new
england and those are the top
competitors for unh
uvm umass uconn they've all
recently updated their life sciences
facilities because there's such a need
in the workforce so it really is an
imperative and a top priority for the
university system which is why the state
support has been so
instrumental
um all right do you have any concerns uh
given the current economic situation
that the country is in with
uh price escalations for projects that
sort of a thing
absolutely
yes absolutely i can tell you again on
the biological sciences initiative
we've signed off
more than a year ago on the guaranteed
maximum price with the construction
manager at risk that's why we chose to
use a construction manager at risk
methodology for that building um but yes
what's happening is
just as the governor mentioned at the
state level
with our overall capital program
we have to really prioritize
when we're looking at spending 65
million dollars our one times
depreciation
we're going through the same
process right now across the university
system on what are the top priorities
because of that escalation
so so you don't expect any other ask
even though
of the state
yes
no
okay thank you not in the capital budget
[Laughter]
we'll get to the other budget don't
worry we'll get there
i i the question i would have is uh
timing i mean i believe construction has
already begun in the initial phase right
correct biological sign phase one is
complete right the addition is complete
and phase two the renovation
started this month
so it got underway yeah and i know
covert obviously threw a wrench into the
timing on a lot of this you guys did it
i
i'll just say you did a phenomenal job
getting the nursing center open that was
the expansion there was just unbelie i
was shocked when they said you were
cutting ribbons i i couldn't believe it
uh so kova i definitely threw a wrench
in a lot of different things um is your
overall schedule off by a bit
on the biological it would be expected
but i didn't know we expect the entire
project will be completed in may of 24.
okay we did have we pulled back for
about six months honestly because
of our own cash flow we didn't know what
to expect during covet at the very
beginning so we pulled back on our
capital program so i would say we're
probably six months off from what we
thought it was going to be six years ago
well that's not too bad okay given
everything we've gone through from the
okay great well thank you guys very much
i really appreciate it and thanks for
coming for definitely kicking us off on
the right foot
uh with that i'm going to we're going to
bring up well let's take
should we just keep plowing through um
they're here we we actually can't start
until the time on the schedule oh oh yep
okay so
we're three minutes is that is that
clock right i don't know
okay great so we have four minutes and
then i will come up and torture the
department of energy a little bit so
thank you guys very much we'll take a
you
okay it is now 9 30
and would like to call the department of
energy
hey
just
give a minute for people to
okay would you like to begin okay thank
you
good morning my name is jared chocoin
and i'm the commissioner of the
department of energy thank you for the
opportunity to present our our capital
budget request
the department administers the federal
low-income home energy assistance
program and the federal weatherization
assistance program
for both programs the department
contracts with the five community action
agencies to process applications and pay
vendors and contractors for both
programs
currently the software that the
community action agencies use to process
applications
and run reports for both programs is
outdated
insufficient for federal rep reporting
and not very nimble when changes need to
be made
the software no longer meets the demands
of these very large programs
using these federal funds the department
will purchase new software that will
gain considerable administrative
efficiencies for these important
assistance programs um
and uh i can tell you from our
experience over the last year or so it's
it's very much needed
with that i'd be happy to answer any
a quick question
given the importance of this program
given what's been happening to energy
rates how are you situated for the next
year or so until this this money can get
to you sure great question thank you um
we have an action plan in place for this
coming fall
we've been working with the caps earlier
than we typically would on making sure
that the system is going to be able to
handle um the needs of this fall
one issue that we ran into last year
was we we increased the benefit
um pretty substantially in the fuel
assistance program and as a result of
trying to
make that change in the software we
encountered a number of
obstacles so we're starting earlier this
year to make sure we can address those
i was uh looking at the summary item and
i noticed this is both for fap and for
whap and i'm gathering that you can use
it for fap and wap and that will help
you interface with the cap
yes
good
thank you um
unfortunately i understood what the
in your summary you also talk and i
remember that we provided
um some funds for the replacements
software in a previous capital budget
um
what are your intentions with that money
just to let it lapse or what
so we're asking for a lap extension
of the 316 000 from the last budget into
um the
2425 biennium
to be used on this same project
absolutely yes okay so the total amount
will be much more than what is shown
commissioner chacoin thanks for bringing
this project forward just for the for
the edification of the committee uh
one of the first meetings i had with a
head of agency back in 2015 when i
joined was
what was before osi and they were
talking about the need to replace this
system over seven years ago so um thanks
for bringing this forward it is it is
much needed and i'm glad that it's
happening now and
doit offers full support
okay thank you very much thank you and
you
morning it is 9 45 and i would like to
invite the department of intervention
technology
to give their presentation
well good morning members of the
committee once again dennis goulet
the commissioner for the department of
information technology
we have three requests to talk about
today the first
is
on page two and it's our cyber security
once again we have cyber security needs
um and i and uh
uh normally when you look at this slide
you're you're probably thinking wow
there's a bunch of geek speak on here
that that isn't very comprehensible and
normally we try to avoid that but in
this case we did it because it's
you know if you were interested in um
these are very common uh terminologies
that are used in the industry right now
and if you were interested in
researching any of this that you'd find
it under this terminology and you know
on the internet but i will break it down
for you in a way that's that's a bit
more comprehensible um
basically um the way we look at cyber
managing cyber security is in terms of
events
the state
processes millions of events per month
thankfully most of which are minor or
that we handle right away i'll give you
some examples of what an event could be
an event could be you know a bad actor
in a foreign country or nation state who
attempts to get into our network and
fails
an event could be a
failed login attempt on a critical
system
an event could be a successful
ransomware ransom of a pc in our
environment
an event could be an email
that successfully makes it through to an
inbox that has either malware in it or a
link to malware that could potentially
ransom the state and so we're dealing
with millions and millions of these
events
so
one of the things that has to happen is
your event management capability your
s-i-e-m
capability
needs to needs to continually get better
so that's an area that a gap that we've
identified recently and
you know are desiring to work on the the
other thing that's going on now is that
our our enemies whether they be foreign
actors
um or uh with um
with malicious intent or commercial
actors with ie trying to extract money
with malicious intent are increasingly
using um
ai technology
to
figure out where the vulnerabilities are
so it's not just a human on the end of a
computer looking at things anymore it's
that automated intelligence that's
seeking to find where vulnerabilities
are in the state network and exploit
them
and you know one really good example is
um you know some companies will you know
put up a vulnerable server on the
outside of their network just to see
what happens with nothing important on
it and typically
in less than 20 minutes
if you put one up in less than 20
minutes
bad actors will find it and begin to
exploit it so that's how effective they
are at at getting to this stuff so two
things we you know in that area what we
want to do is we want to get better at
managing these millions millions of
events using
this
automated response technology
and and also get better at
figuring out which ones we should be
paying attention to and not
the second current state bullet identity
and access management that is simple
it's i'm logging into a system
and can i do i get in there or not am i
the really dennis goulet and am i really
authorized to do those things um so one
of the things that's come out since
since the advent of ransomware and i
want to just take a a little detour here
on ransomware for a moment um in in the
old days of cyber security it used to be
oh we were worried about exfiltration of
information like personal information or
um no credit card information or social
security numbers well that's still very
important we don't want bad actors to be
stealing that information but it's much
worse now because
um
with the event of ransomware now um the
continuity of government can be affected
um so you know if it's a critical system
gets ransomed it's no longer providing
the citizen services that we stood it up
for so the importance there is is
greater
in what's become kind of the gold
standard for protecting there's a bunch
of different things you can do to
protect from ransomware but one of the
gold standards is
strong identity and access management so
and in particular multi-factor
authentication so that's an area where
we're working hard to have both improve
our our profile around the executive
branch as well as
make it consistent so that we know that
all of our critical systems and the and
the pcs because a pc is a critical
system typically
the way a successful large-scale
ransomware attack
starts is on an individual's device
whether it's a phone or a pc or a tablet
the last thing i would say is
the national institutes of standards and
technology nist continues to evolve its
its standards as it relates to cyber
security so we're always
trying to keep up
with that and so that's really what that
third bullet means and without going to
the desired end state through that for
you in specifics really what we're
trying to do is address those three
areas and improve our profile
with respect to those i'll i'll stop on
uh here for questions on cyber security
thank you commissioner
assuming you you receive that amount of
money or somewhere in there to do the
the program enhancements would they all
be done in one biennium
or are we talking spreading it out over
a couple
um what we've seen typically in the
recent i'd
i'll admit we've been asking for cyber
security money every biennium since i've
been here and i think before
and that's the sad state of things in
cyber security we have been
operationalizing
most or all of what's been granted to us
by the legislature each biennium and i
would expect that to be true in this
i have a question it relates to this and
the we we've all heard about uh
chip shortages in it and the other
supply chain issues which have
impacted
this industry are there any supply chain
issues that you're aware of which would
either delay or hinder
the projects that you're bringing before
us today
in in this case no we have some existing
projects right now particularly our our
arpa funded infrastructure enhancement
project the network piece of that
we got we got about three quarters of
the equipment in pretty quickly and the
other quarter is dribbling in really
really slowly so that that did impact
there but we're not actually buying
physical things here with respect to
this this would be licensing services
and and
and implementing services so i wouldn't
anticipate supply chain being a problem
uh labor throughout the um there's a
multiple statistics around the country
but professional
cyber security experts
is a challenge in the industry so
companies are are challenged with that
states are challenged with that that's
good morning dennis this goes with this
project but probably all three of them
um if this isn't the purchase of
software which it doesn't sound like
it's more licensing or maybe in-house
programming are you experiencing
staffing resource issues or constraints
yourself with these projects or as
you're assisting other state agencies
maybe you could just talk a little bit
about where you stand with that yes um
we uh thanks that's a really good
question the um
we are currently um you know have the
highest level of vacancy that we've had
um in doit um in the history of the
department and i've checked because i
i've been here seven years but even
before that it's been a department's
been around a while and i had my hr
folks check and you know this is this is
the highest
um and in the industry you know we're
all chasing after the same resources so
it is a challenge but
uh cyber security is one of those hot
places where a lot of money is flowing
in with venture capital monies for
startup companies and they're paying
extremely well
so they are attracting the private
sector is attracting uh talent pretty
effectively that's not an area where
we're having trouble there's certain
other areas where we are but not in
okay like to continue i'll move on to
the next one very quickly
i want to try to keep us on our
on schedule
um financial systems modernization um
you know we have a an old fine old kind
of homegrown finance system that we've
been running doit
on for
many many years now and since its
formation
it really is time to modernize that
for the purpose of efficiency and
transparency
in maturing our processes and also doing
a better job of interoperating with our
friends over at administrative services
in new hampshire first so i won't go in
too much uh detail on that but we'll be
happy to um
to field questions on that
but it does i will say that you know we
have staff that are retiring that know
this old system and there's no way of
hiring staff to to do the to do the old
one but potentially for a new system
that was out there we we could uh
bless you
dennis as you're replacing this is there
any opportunity to use the current new
hampshire first for some of your
activities
yeah i think that would be a really
important
to me anyway that would be a really
important part of how we approach this
is we don't recreate the wheel so i i
will commit to you that we're gonna
look really hard at that and consult and
collaborate with you folks to make sure
that we're not doing that or creating
downstream problems for you that were
unanticipated
all right and finally and this
question i'm sorry so um
currently a homegrown system
is this
software that has already been produced
and is in use
throughout the country or throughout the
world
it's
produced and is in use in new hampshire
in my department
it's the homegrown correct right but i
meant the replacements oh yes what we
would do is we probably we would um
do an rfi and find out what's a request
for information we'd find out what's out
there in the market we've already done
some some of that so we kind of have an
idea of what's out there
and
so
we would be looking for common off the
shelf software not something we would
develop ourselves
all right finally um i.t service
management is really the
art and science of taking whatever
resources we have and effectively
applying them to the support of our
customers which is the you know
our final customers the citizens of new
hampshire but the intermediate customer
are our agency partners that we work
we've been running the same system for
many years it's it's done an okay job of
kind of transactional
one-to-one um
service management but
but but the world has evolved past that
and now there's a lot more
sophistication in in the science and the
measurement of how effective we are we
don't have the ability to leverage that
with the existing tools that we have
today
mature that over period of a couple
biennia the first biennial would be
analysis finding out what's out there
how much it costs but also as we state
in the um
in the
report here that we would like to
enhance the front end of it to improve
uh the online services that we offer to
the employees of the state to make them
more efficient right now you can send in
an email or you can call the help desk
but
i think automating and improving the
services that we can offer online would
improve services
better leverage the pretty small staff
we have who supports all of the
executive branch employees
and
and and improve end service to the
citizens through that efficiency that we
any questions
thank you this is one of the ones i
think the governor
alluded to when he talked about spending
money in one bietium
and then um
coming back for more
if we only got the first phase
what would happen
well
according to our plans the first phase
would improve would would help us
understand what it was going to cost we
are already spending money on the
existing system so it's it's not a full
new new
um although
the
the cost of systems has increased with
the cost of everything else so you are
correct there would be an incremental uh
if we only got the first half we'd be
better off than we are now but it
you mentioned that the cost of systems
has been increasing uh can you give me
some idea on how much they've increasing
relative to other goods and services
that we
would typically be aware of well
the average inflation rate is 8.6
our friends over at the administrative
offices of the court have the same
system we presently have they just did a
request for quote and the
the systems that are available now are
um between 2.5 and 3x
and we we expect that the existing
system will likely be retired within the
some some years because the existing
system is a
traditional on-premise
software
most of the industry's going away from
that and they're going into you know the
what called euphemistically the cloud
where it's actually software as a
service so when you buy it you're not
actually putting software in your data
center you're actually accessing it
on the internet so that's where the in
the software industry as a whole is
going and we expect
we will be forced out of using this at
some point anyway much like we have with
okay
question
so in addition to
um you know whatever
um you know how however much the
management system would end up costing
to buy
off-the-shelf software to implement this
then uh because it's on the cloud is
there a subscription
to that on an annual basis yes we have
annual and that's what i was referring
to we have annual maintenance that we
pay on this now
um so
rather than paying annual maintenance
what what you uh we'd be paying a
subscription which includes the main
which typically if you do the math would
include
maintenance plus the systems that it's
running on amortized over the useful
life of the system press plus a profit
margin for the company so it nets out
similarly over time but
often there's a larger investment bump
in the beginning so software as a
service has a smaller investment bump at
the beginning and then a higher ongoing
run rate because you're paying for that
for the entire loaded cost of the system
over time versus in one lump big payment
up front
and another and no lumps later so you
have that five or seven year uh refresh
that has to happen where you you would
tr in a traditional model you'd have a
big cost bump where you don't in
software as a service typically
and i'd like to invite department of
good morning
i'm charlie arlinghaus i'm the
commissioner of administrative services
and who are you
i'm karen rantamackie director of plant
and property
so what we're going to do you see on
your agenda you've got i think it's five
or maybe six bullets in front of you and
so we're going to start we're going to
talk about
property in the and stuff like that and
then at the end i'm going to talk about
the i.t thing
um
the big it thing and there's a big
elephant in the room that we're going to
talk about at the same time but uh in
the interim uh karen i'll start by
talking about property um because
because karen's a professional engineer
and uh i'm a professional
well i'm not a professional engineer
let's just go with that um and um
but i wanted i want to set the context
for what she's going to talk about a
little bit
um
i it was interesting listening to the
university system talk about their capex
spending and their target goals and you
know percentage of deprecia depreciation
and all that and i thought wouldn't it
be wonderful if we could get to that and
we basically spend um the change we can
find in the in the couch cushions and
then fix the things that are falling
apart worst
is our is our sort of state policy for
about 20 or 30 years on
on how we deal with the with the capital
infrastructure it's a slight
exaggeration
but
we talk sometimes how do you determine
what to what to go in and i i'm going to
tell the story which i think i've told
the last two capital budget hearings
about six bucket leaks
and 12 bucket leaks
and karen is very nice not to roll her
eyes um but
um i had a discussion once um karen's
predecessor steve laurenson so karen and
steve and i uh were meeting and he
talked about um our requests are the are
the 12 bucket leaks none of the six
bucket leaks and i said i'm not really
familiar with that term what does it
mean
and he said well i'll give an example at
the dairy courthouse
when it and very might be wrong but when
it rains
we put a bucket on certain desks where
there's a leak
to catch the water as it drips in and
and there are places where people the
computer goes on the left of the desk
not the right because we don't want it
to drip on it and if there's six of them
it's a six bucket leak and i thought oh
i could have figured that out um
but he said we don't ask for money to
replace six bucket leaks because we
don't have enough money we only do the
12 bucket leaks um and that's the
state's general approach to um to
capital costs and and building uh
maintaining buildings
and so we're going to talk to you
instead of talking to you about
um there's 36 of 38 projects on the
initial list
but the governor um
tightened our focus to about six of them
um so we're going to talk about that and
um
we do have pictures we can send around i
don't have copies for everyone because
they're in color and we don't have
uh the resources to make multiple copies
of all these but um
these are just a couple of our
facilities that um well we have the kent
wing which is part of main building
and
the paisley annex which is also part of
main building to kind of show how
extreme
our buildings can go if we don't put the
money into them and and and do the
maintenance that they require um
one of the projects that we won't be
talking about today but we did request
funding for is a comprehensive paving
project so we also have some pictures to
show examples of you know what some of
the pavement and our
yeah so feel free to take a look and
okay so i already let you know i'm karen
rantamacky i'm the director of plant
property for department of
administrative services and today i'll
be providing an overview of the projects
requested for the division of plant
property within the department of
administrative services
this division is made up of the bureaus
of general services court facilities
facilities and asset management and we
also provide energy management services
to state agencies and oversee the
capital emergency fund
that fund is available to all agencies
for unforeseen emergency repairs
as we all navigate the changing economy
new hampshire state government as well
as the rest of the world has encountered
project delays lack of available labor
and increased cost on the majority of
its projects and i mentioned that
because we've seen this
throughout the past few years that our
projects are coming in higher than we
anticipated
i was asked to speak about seven
projects today starting with the bureau
of general services and the mechanical
repairs needed at the health and human
services and environmental services
building at 29 hayes and drive
this is a large project that would
replace two existing chillers
that are nearing the end of their useful
life clinton property has already
authorized the design work to begin on
this project due to its urgent nature so
we've done testing and we found that the
these chillers are nearing the end of
their useful useful life and will likely
need to be uh replaced soon hopefully
not
before we get approval for this funding
these chillers are part of the critical
system that regulates the climate in the
public health labs
and that facility cannot operate without
these units
the second project under the bureau of
general services is at the emergency
operations center and that's another
critical building that must remain
operational the various repairs needed
at this facility include repairs to the
water supply tanks
and those are used
for the facility to remain open in case
we're unable to gain access to the
public water supply
also repairs to the fuel oil tank which
allows the emergency generator to run
and the installation of an emergency
power connection which would allow us to
bring in a portable emergency generator
um the bureau of court facilities i'll
talk about next
um
do you want me to stop in between or no
okay okay um
and the bureau of court facilities works
in conjunction with the judicial branch
to prioritize their request so their top
request for this coming biennium is for
the construction of a new courthouse in
rochester
the funding for the design was approved
in the last biennium and that design is
underway now so the 14.8 million dollar
request would fund the construction of
the rochester circuit court
and the existing facility does not meet
current courthouse standards and has no
space to include the rochester family
division which is currently located
elsewhere and and has proved to be
confusing for the clientele
the next bureau is the bureau of
facility and asset management and we've
requested funding to increase the number
of heating zones in the fair building
this building is nearly 100 000 square
feet and it's currently heated with just
five zones the lack of sufficient
sufficient zones means areas of the
building are consistently too hot or too
cold and when boilers boilers are
adjusted to compensate it results in
overheating and wasted energy
this is typically the most common uh
request that my staff get in terms of
service calls throughout the day so
we're always responding to people that
are you know complaining about the space
temperature
next is the office of state energy
management
and this
uh office as i mentioned earlier assists
all state agencies with energy saving
projects in state-owned facilities
agencies submit reports annually on the
projects that they would like to do
projects are evaluated by energy
management staff and those with
favorable payback numbers are funded
some examples from this year's list
include projects for insulation high
efficiency heat pumps for heating and
cooling boilers and furnaces windows and
lighting controls so with that request
we request a lump sum and then it's
allocated throughout the biennium to
those projects that i mentioned earlier
additionally the state energy manager
submitted a second request for funds to
upgrade the remaining fluorescent or
other older technology lighting to leds
and this would be throughout
all of our state-owned buildings
throughout the state not just
administrative services but all agencies
this relatively simple project could
save the state a considerable amount in
electricity costs if it were to be
completed
there are also some economies of scale
that could be exploited if the project
was undertaken as a whole and not
piecemeal as funding has allowed or when
other work was done in a facility the
state has slowly started to migrate to
led lighting
it is estimated that about half of the
state square footage still needs to be
converted to be to be converted to led
the average payback period for this
lighting when so solely considering the
energy cost is seven and a half years
and this would also result in
significant maintenance savings as well
as a better work environment for our
staff
and then finally the division of plant
property is requesting one and a half
million in emergency funds and the
emergency fund is available to any state
agency for emergency repair work to any
of its state-owned facilities
in the recent past the emergency fund
has been used for elevator repairs
repairing leaks in hvac piping boiler
repairs and structural stabilization of
underground tunnels
and that concludes my testimony
just a couple things to put in context
what we do for people there are three
major bureaus in plant and property that
manage all of the state that managed a
building for all three branches of
government
we manage the office buildings we manage
the courthouses we manage the
the buildings in which
people work or we store things
what we don't manage are
patient or residential
housing so for example
think of corrections as a residential
if you will
um but hospitals we don't do glenn cliff
we don't do the sununu center we don't
do um
uh new hampshire hospital we don't do
the prison um but we do if the
department of x is working somewhere
this is what we do there are two pieces
of plant and property though that that
serve
all state buildings regardless the one
is the emergency fund because
emergencies are not confined to
they happen everywhere and the other is
energy we do energy efficiency in in
hundreds of buildings not the
90 or 95 buildings that are that are
part of our direct management so so
that's the piece where that is i
mentioned before that that there's a lot
to fix
i mean frankly at on some point if you
wanted to fund capital budget projects
somewhere between 12 million and 800
million
we would be able to spend it easily and
be fixing stuff that needs fixing
we're going to work
probably over probably toward the end of
the summer
with some legislators on the the house
finance in particular has expressed an
interest in
in management and
i committed to well initially at fiscal
to representative edwards but to talk
about happy to talk to you about what we
do and what we track and how we track it
and we're built he apparently has a
building
interest i think is the right expression
um and what i'm what i've offered is to
tour buildings because people are
occasionally you know
you get invited to like dra which is the
nicest building in state government or
employment security which is the second
nicest building in state government
probably you have very few meetings in
the main building or johnson or
laundering
um where large portions of those three
buildings are just dumps
and um
and it's the kind of thing we like to
show people so um we're gonna pause
before we do um i.t stuff so if people
sure representative
thank you um commissioner
um
looking at your initial list
the longer one there are several items
that
potentially could be paid with arpa
funds hvac and some other how seriously
have we been looking at using
those type of funds for any of these
requests
that are there and how far along are we
with with that
there was a there was one arpa fund
project approved for hvac and i think
it's 20 million dollars 24 million
depending but some of it's dedicated
um and um
we're doing everything we can with that
and sometimes the hvac work is done in
conjunction with another project
and it's certainly something we'll look
at that's the only arpa use that that
has come up so for
for non-hvac work there is no arpa
funding
um but for hvac work there is although
there might be there's we've had some
discussions with our with um
oh my god i forgot their name gopher
excuse me
um with gopher but other than that how
far along would you say we are on hvac
um yeah just to add a little bit of
detail we have about six or seven uh
facilities that we're working on
currently with hvac unfortunately the 24
million doesn't go as far as we all
think it should um
with hvac because they're all you know
multi-million dollar projects with big
big complicated buildings and um
everything has become you know more
expensive than it was a couple years ago
so we do we are utilizing that i just
checked it this morning i think we have
um out of the 24 million i think we have
about 20 of it committed
um to projects with a little bit left
over for things that might go over
budget or you know one more project that
good morning
um
the pictures that you passed around were
were very interesting um
you're not requesting funds for those
projects in this
can you tell us um about how many
you know how many square feet are
you pass pictures around
you have a rough ballpark on that
if you want to think in broad global
terms about the buildings that we manage
there are the buildings in concord and
the buildings that are not in concord
the buildings not in concord are
typically um court facilities but not
exclusively court facilities and the
buildings in concord except for the ones
with the label court or not
we manage about
2.2 ish million square feet of office
space i think in concord and then
space that we currently describe as
unusable
which would be those pictures which
would be so think of bancroft kent wing
peasley annex uh
kent annex
a bunch of the the sort of tentacle
additions to the main building on the
state hospital campus and most of the
dreadful stuff is on the state the old
state hospital campus
i would say that's what do you think
four or five hundred thousand
i'd say less than that but
so so i think the main building if you
take the whole thing bancroft excluded
is about 300 000 square feet and we're
using about 200 000 square feet does
that sound about right and then bancroft
is another
45 000 square feet is that right yeah i
would say 40 but yeah yeah so
so probably about 150 000
that looks similar to the pictures that
i passed around the broader point about
the picture though that i want to make
sure i make is is um
so when i started as commissioner which
is which is almost exactly five years
ago now um
one of the first things i did is i i
took a
a tour for lack of a better word of a
bunch of our facilities i was actually
excited about going to the pleasant
street campus because they have tunnels
and i kind of like tunnels
and they're actually kind of cool
but
we walked through at some point we
walked through the main building and
there are pieces of it that are all
different so we entered the building
through kent
um old kent and kent annex and then we
walked through the regular part of the
main building we went to paisley annex
and we ended up in the north pavilion
and what's what's typical of those three
buildings and there's no reason
everybody would know necessarily what
those are
is
we walk in kent and somebody said to me
don't look around look down
and if the floor looks like you might
fall through it you probably will so
step carefully and the piles of
stuff are exactly what you think they
are because we can't keep all the birds
out
in raccoons and
things like that
this is a building that is
probably
gone or close to gone
we went to paisley annex which we were
which we'd been doing some cleaning work
on you know cleaning out all the
accumulated detritus of many
of a century and a half
um and then we're starting to do
structural work which uh turned out that
it's probably not habitable um at least
not for anything very heavy
um and then we ended up in north
pavilion i think it's called north
pavilion anyway which is
um
lovely
very nice office space modern cubicles
and you wouldn't know you were in 150
year old building i mean it it it could
be it was one of the nicer spaces in
state government and it's sort of an a b
and c thing if we don't spend money on
buildings they will decay
the worst example of that is the is the
thing in laconia
a whole bunch of buildings that are now
of now a fitting monument to it's some
of its horrible uses because they're
decayed horrible and we can't let people
in because you'll get i mean we don't
let people in wearing hazmat suits right
now
because the mold is so bad
and we don't want buildings to get that
way so that so we have buildings in
various stages very few
are at the point of laconia
not that many are at the point of kent
that you looked at you know a couple
hundred thousand square feet but every
building has the potential to get there
except
probably walker employment security and
dra
thank you
substantial amount of square footage
lying dormant
a
question the how recent are the cost
estimates used to put together that you
put together for these projects and do
they are are they fairly recent and the
fact that they've taken into account the
dramatic increase in prices we've seen
but more importantly
do they take into account the rising
prices we're still expecting certainly
i i'd say most of the pricing is from
the february time frame but i i agree
even between february and today
there's been a huge shift in pricing
um and i can't say what they're gonna
look like next summer when the funds
actually get approved
so so all the capital budget stuff is
you know the deadline to submit it is
february something right and so agencies
are our agency too
are putting them together in a time
frame in december and january of last
year
typically you know the the piece of the
process where the the projects that make
an initial first cut by
the chief executive
are sent to public works for estimate
those estimates often result in very
different numbers in part because
public workers works is charged with
with taking into account um current
pricing and trying to predict for the
future god knows how they're going to
predict for the future this year
um but i but i would say that almost
every project that you're going to see
before you um that's going to be an
issue and you know by the time it gets
you know some of the estimates are going
to be quite old and god knows what's
happening with inflation and the good
news though i would bet the payback
number for the energy projects
is quicker because energy rates uh
inflation may be eight and a half but
heating oil is 93
so
you know some of and electric costs are
going nuts so we might have a quicker
um commissioner you were talking about
building sticky and stuff i think it was
about 18 years ago we did a master plan
on the hughes
um office park and for a while we
followed it that we didn't i would
suggest that you look at maybe
requesting
something in in the capital budget or
your operating budget to do something
similar with
a larger scope of buildings you know are
we ever going to fix them are we going
to have to spend money to
tear them down
and to have a plan
to present to the legislature you know
for a multi-biennium process to to do
all of that because
doing things two years at a time just
doesn't seem to cut it and even when we
have a master plan we don't always keep
going on it because other things take
priority like a prison well i would like
a person um
uh jesus then that price tag god knows
if we'll build anything else
um the um
well great minds think alike
so uh karen and i have been talking
recently about master plans and and for
for committee members who don't know
there was a master plan done on
the pleasant street campus in
uh 95 and then the second one in 2004
and the 2004 one is the one that you can
find
online buried somewhere on the public
works website um you have to dig a
little to get there but you can get
there but you're right that a lot of it
you know at the time spalding was i
think the only building that had been
recently renovated
and um and the rest had not
but we looked at it and you know is that
is that where we want to go now is that
where we by the way a lot of it is still
if you dig that out
not bad
um but um
we were talking and
i was discussing with karen whether we
do multiple master plans like you know
one for hazen one for downtown one for
the campus or we just do one for state
buildings in concord
which i think might make more sense
because
what you end up doing on you know
downtown or on hazen is probably
influenced by whether you've met needs
like what if we take
doit for example and plop them in a
cornfield on clinton street
um i mean in a building right not just
in a cornfield but um
it would kind of change what we do on
okay
thank you
okay if there's nothing else on
buildings um no don't go anywhere
because there could still be something
on buildings
um there's uh i want to talk to you
about i.t there is there is one it
project on your list but it's not the
big it project there's a request for a
learning management system
um the state in something like 2015
purchased uh moodle
um i think literally as a result of a
of a training project that
some bet course as part of their
certified public manager work had come
up with the idea to do a learning
management system and we bought an
off-the-shelf
very free
is it freeware i think that they call it
open source so it's free except until
you try to run it and then it's less a
lot less free yes and it's a lot less
free and it's been worth every bit that
we paid for it um it's it's perfectly
reasonably adequate if you're not trying
to do anything complicated
um but uh learning management if the
state is going to invest in in employee
training is essential and uh somebody
said at fiscal a month ago that
you know i believe a learning management
system is part of any any competent hr
operation and i'm sure that the state
has a pretty good one and i said you
know the
some of those statements are true
um so so that's a piece um it would
probably cost about 750 000 and we could
integrate it into new hampshire first
the bigger picture is new hampshire
first there is not
there is not here
a capital request for
an update to the state's enterprise
system the state's enterprise system is
the computer system that runs the entire
operation financials budget payroll hr
procurement pick something i'm sure i
left 12 things out but
basically everything you do is done
through one giant system administered by
our department of financial data
management it's much more than just
financial data
the state in in 2007 and 8
stood up a new system after having a
homegrown one that had fallen apart
um it wasn't homegrown we just stopped
ever updating it and keeping up with the
updates and so it you know at that time
there were you know two guys left who
knew how to do it and they were both
gonna retire
um so we set up a new one and uh the
winning bidder at that time was lawson
lawson has since been bought by infor in
for us who manages our system we are at
a place
we do upgrade the system now which is
really important um
for a comparison purpose should this
think of it this way should the state
try to run as computers on windows
windows 95
or should we keep going forward and
upgrading every time we go to 98 and
then
whatever followed that like was 98 is
what i have at home so
um
but uh we kept carrying forward and kept
updating the system so that it is
continually supported
the next upgrade is is called going to
the cloud it has a component of it
the upgrade happens to be also called
cloud suite but it is a
massive update to the state's financial
system in particular we are at a point
where our staff and duit are in
discussions about what what do we do
because the state has functionally three
choices
uh the one choice is to do nothing to
decide that continually upgrading the
system is too expensive this is a choice
the state has made in the past on
occasion
the upgrades really are expensive and
they cost a lot of money every year to
keep up to date
and at some point you can just get off
the ferris wheel and stop then
eventually that collapses and your
computer system looks like the pictures
of kentling that i passed out
and that's where we've had problems in
the past and there there are legacy
systems in various
holes inside state government where that
still exists
um the second thing you can do is buy a
whole new system a whole new erp
we're going to upgrade massive upgrade
is the time when you might want to
bid and reprocure and you look at oracle
and workday and and six others i'm sure
that uh make
um systems um and in for the current
product um
that's more expensive
but it's starting from scratch i would
say that's one of the two options that
we're actively considering i think that
we're not actively considering doing
nothing
i think i think dennis's team and our
team would both agree that doing nothing
is
um silly
um
the
the middle ground if you will is to
upgrade the current system
but if you upgrade the current system
you have to do it right and you have to
do it in a fairly expensive manner
and the
the rough cost estimates and you know we
haven't gotten to the point of doing
really really good cost estimates but in
terms of not just buying the software
but hiring the implementation teams
because it's not something people can do
in their spare time
we make the mistake a lot of times where
we add a project
on the presumption that no one's
actually working
and that they don't actually have a job
and they can just do this on the side
and um it's possible there might be
somebody somewhere where that's possible
but none of them work for me
and so that's uh that's not how that
works so we'd have to hire people so
probably 20 to 25 million would be the
cost of uh at the low end
of some sort of migration maybe a little
higher than that frankly given what's
going on with it
costs
um and the upper end of it with the with
the new procurement could be as much as
90 or 100 i'm looking at dennis to say
i'm crazy
you're not
i'm not there we go at least not in this
respect um anyway that's where we are
we're in discussions dennis's team and
my team have talked we are likely in the
um
in the late spring early summer to have
a meeting with the
governor governor
who as you know has strong perspectives
on
technology
um and its uses
um and then at that point we might be we
might be coming back that's out there
and it's huge it's not men's prison huge
but it's you know
men's halfway house huge if you know
are there any questions if i may
just
one caution
i know that on house
committee on public works and highways
there is growing concern
about how much
i.t
software and other things we are bonding
for 20 years
every time somebody comes in with with a
new great idea
when we have buildings that are falling
apart
i don't know how we balance that
but i just caution that there is that
sentiment that goes
well if we spend 50 million dollars of
125 on software
what building falls apart
so
yes so i resemble that remark in
multiple ways right and we i had a
conversation the other day where i
talked about um
you know real capital projects and i.t
capital projects and i unfortunately i
think i said it in front of dennis but
um i didn't mean to but it's the same
thing right we we have these we have
these two tranches
and um
and how do you balance it when when your
your
your price tag is 125 million and
and it's the people who do the i know
what karen would suggest we do
and i know what dennis would suggest we
do and i don't think that's the same
thing
i'd like to invite the community college
system of new hampshire
good morning i'm mark rubinstein serving
as the chancellor of the community
college system of new hampshire
joined by my colleague matt moore who
many of you will know from his long
service
on behalf of the state and the community
college system
overseeing our facilities
first i want to thank you for the
opportunity to present this morning
you have already a comprehensive packet
and i don't want to take the time to
walk through all of it i think like to
try and prioritize the time you have for
questions
but i would like to just address a few
key points just for background
virtually everything that we do is to
support the workforce here in the state
of new hampshire
this past year the community college
system
conferred degrees to 280 nurses in fact
over the last 12 years 3 400 nurses
graduated by the community college
system of new hampshire
during that same time
over 800 automotive technicians nearly a
thousand welders
2 000 degrees and certificates in
business a third of those in accounting
so our work is really about preparing
students to engage and grow in the new
our needs for capital in turn are built
on that need the ability to sustain and
expand those efforts and ultimately what
we need to be able to do is deliver
those programs throughout the state so
our ability to concentrate in a single
location uh would undercut our ability
having said that you will see from our
packet some key projects
little hall at nhti
turner hall at lakes region community
college
both of those buildings uh approaching
60.
i've been on the earth longer than they
are
they haven't i i know how aged they are
firsthand
having said that
if you look at those buildings
what you're going to see are aged
facilities worn facilities
not the inspiring locations that we want
to deliver forward-looking programs that
our faculty try and inspire students
with and some to some degree the
challenge that we face is that those
facilities are are worn to the point of
concern for health and life safety we've
got asbestos that we've got to deal with
in little hall
we've got roofs that are deteriorating
we're somewhere between the university
system and and commissioner arlinghaus
we're we're not we're not just looking
for change where we absolutely need the
12 bucket uh situations
but we do have some buildings that that
require more attention than we can
currently address and need support from
the state for those
what we're ultimately looking for isn't
to rebuild the same buildings that we've
we've had for those 60 years but we'd
like to be able to ensure that those are
functional spaces those are safe spaces
that we have the flexibility to adapt
curricula over time
so that those can
better reflect the ways in which
teaching and learning happen they can
change with the economy and the need for
academic program
one of the characteristics of the 1960s
when those buildings were built in some
cases a tendency towards specialization
so we've got specialized spaces
what we're looking for is to be able to
recast that in in larger more flexible
options so that we can integrate
learning across programs and again adapt
the other thing that you'll notice in
our presentation it's also reflected in
critical maintenance just some
overarching priorities
energy
secure building envelopes and life
safety issues so you'll see hvac roofs
sprinklers asbestos mitigation those
sorts of things
those are just fundamental needs for the
buildings to be appropriate for the use
of our our students and our faculty to
deliver the programs
so
let me stop at this point and see if
yeah
my question is one similar that i asked
for at for unh and that is the the
competition for students is intense
and how do these capital improvements
relate to your plan to not only
retain students currently in your
program but attract new ones and if you
could talk about your competition
and some of the things they might be
doing and how
you're either falling behind or keeping
pace with them with these projects well
we we've recently surveyed prospective
students and and parents for our
traditional age students and we've
gotten significant feedback that
facilities matter
in some ways teaching and learning are
hard to see unless you're actually there
as a student
so you look at the physical surroundings
and you get a sense of of what the what
the commitment is what the quality is
and to the extent that as i said before
we've got forward-looking faculty very
creative and entrepreneurial and
thoughtful
and they're teaching disciplines in stem
and health care and other things that
should be very future oriented but
they're doing it in buildings that
that even their parents think look
outdated that's a problem the other part
of competition is a little bit different
for us
significant number of our students are
working adults they're already in the
workforce and what they're looking for
is a learning environment that's
comparable consistent with the places
where they're working if they see a
setting that doesn't look like the place
where they work doesn't look like the
type of environment engineering
facility or type of machining facility
or culinary arts or automotive you know
that that's problematic so what we're
really trying to do is
not just sell against competition we're
actually trying to build congruence
between what they and their employers
recognize because a portion of our work
as i said is with working adults already
in the workforce cultivating
relationships with their employers as
partners and we've got to be able to
deliver programs in settings that look
very consistent with the world in which
they're going to be expected to operate
i know in the past we've partnered with
industries and and groups to help fund
some of these
projects
the dental association and others have
stepped forward and looking at some of
these is there anybody on your staff or
on the board who is out trying to beat
the bushes to see if somebody would help
with
the transportation related technology or
the
energy or any of the rest of that to
help offset some of these costs rather
than the state bearing at all when we're
trading their new employees
in short yes we've had good support from
eversource for our our line workers
program milton kat has provided 200 000
to white mountains community college
we've had gifts to lakes region for our
culinary arts program we continue to
look for those opportunities to align
our interests with businesses and to
recognize that it just shared shared
can i uh nice to see you again and i'd
very clever of you to bring smokey with
you i presume that when you go to house
public works he'll be in the front row
um
just saying
um the um i
for the context of the committee um
to what extent people often uh too often
equate the community college system in
your university system in terms of share
of state funding
how what percentage of your capital
program in a given year
does the state capital project represent
ballpark
do you mean compared to our operating
budget no let's let's say like what's
your your total capital funds is is the
state share is the state capital
appropriation
all of the capital investment you make
or is it 10 of your total capital
investment
in a given year it's the majority of it
um as the chancellor mentioned earlier
we do seek other
funds from eversource
and we have donations as he's mentioned
but
it's a small push percentage but our we
do
put quite a few of our operating funds
into
you know repairs we've got
our culinary program at lakes region for
instance was done through grants and
donations we didn't even get any capital
dollars for that but it's it's a small
amount but it's
the opportunity at that in that case to
move an off-site
culinary program to be on site
i just wanted to point out for the for
the benefit of everybody here that the
you know the university system has a
large capital program and the state is a
small bit of it
for the community college system um
questions
so i'm looking at your at your handout
um
you have a detail page
i think it's like page nine
that that says year twenty four twenty
five nineteen million one hundred
thousand dollars for a total
and then
a little bit further on there's an
appendix
and it lists specific projects which
total out to be
three million one hundred fifty thousand
is the three million one hundred fifty
thousand your request for
this
capital budget biennium
no this is the the
the appendix with detail is the critical
maintenance it's a subset specifically
of of i want to say smaller projects but
in some cases they're relatively large
but it's just a subset of the total okay
so it's a subset
if you will of the nineteen million one
hundred thousand dollars
yes uh it's line one of the first page
nine that you referred to
um top line um for 24.25 so it's
part of the 19.1 million requests that
is your presentation concluded yes okay
next like to invite the department of
we are passing out um our latest and
greatest um and that is the information
that we will be presenting to you
today
i'm sarah stewart and i serve as the
commissioner of the department of
natural and cultural resources and it's
an honor to be with you today
dncr is home to five divisions the
division of parks and recreation the
division of forests and lands the state
library the division of historical
resources and the new hampshire state
council on the arts
and at our agency we are proud to
protect preserve promote and manage our
state's natural and cultural resources
supporting new hampshire's economy high
quality of life and strengthening the
experiences of our residents and guests
in a moment tom mansfield who is sitting
to my left
who is our lead architect for the agency
will walk you through our five capital
budget priorities but before i hand it
over to tom i want to provide some
general context
our capital budget
needs address the increasing demand for
outdoor experiences as you know new
hampshire is a state position to
accommodate such demand with a wide
variety of experiences within proximity
we are not going to be able to sustain
the level of safety cleanliness and
accessibility without strategic and
consistent investment in our 200 to 300
million dollars worth of infrastructure
these investments make impacts beyond
state park boundaries host communities
see our parks as an asset partner
organizations thrive when we thrive and
the state's overall tourism industry
benefits when state parks are clean safe
available and accessible
as an indication of demand the new
hampshire state park system offers 1419
campsites in 23 campgrounds and we are
fully occupied on weekends and holidays
i also want to remind folks that it was
in 1977 when legislation was passed to
fund a tram replacement project
since then tram 2 has transported nearly
10 million passengers and this tram has
served the state well and is now it is
now time to consider its future
we have also added a request from the
mount washington advisory commission
which has a draft master plan in the
works
this will be the first completed master
plan since 1970 and the commission
strongly believes an environmental and
infrastructure assessment at the summit
is imperative in order to make sound
decisions about future development
capacity and investments on mount
washington
turning to our forest and lands
priorities the state the new hampshire
state forest nursery had a
record-breaking sale season for the
third consecutive year this spring
2022 saw a 67 increase in sales over
2021 and a 73 increase in number of
customers utilizing the new hampshire
state forest nursery
over a five-year span the nursery sales
have increased by over 239 percent
in this capital budget request we lay
out several opportunities to get our
forest and lands infrastructure up to
date and efficient in order to sustain
this growth well into the future
i would like to take a moment to
acknowledge the ongoing support from
this administration for all five of our
divisions as we have endured a few
roller coaster years with covid we would
not be in as strong a position as a
department to provide the array of
constituent services that we do without
your recognition of the impact we make
on communities throughout the state
and now i'll turn it to tom to walk you
good morning good morning
our five capital budget
item requests are as follows
the first one in our top priority is
category we call roofing and repairs
we've been privileged to receive money
in this category
for at least six bienniums that i'm
aware of it's a category that covers
roofing repairs and deferred maintenance
projects that are required to keep the
parks and other dncr facilities
operating and providing services
it provides a source of funding to allow
the department to respond to critical
facilities failures this is things like
water pump failures or septic pump
failures or storm damage
i remember in
2016 we had a storm in april that tore
up the paving at north hampton beach
because we had this funding in place we
were able to have the parking lot
repaired and operational in time for
memorial day
so it's very important to us from that
respect
the roofing component of the of the
project
is something we've been working on for
years and it's going very successfully
we're catching up on deferred
maintenance and the roofing
this proposal
uh outlines work for approximately 350
worth of roofing it would re-roof
something in the order of 80 structures
in our park system and those structures
be
picked through our scheduled maintenance
program we have a database which we call
fixed asset resource management system
or farms
and we assess the roofs and so we can
predict when we think roofs are ready to
be repaired so this this would continue
our program there
a very significant way
the repairs uh
part of the of the
request there are there is a list of
projects which we have included in your
packet
and these are representative of the type
of projects that we'd be doing for
repairs and upgrades and and fire safety
throughout the park system
we do want to point out that we need the
flexibility to respond to emergencies as
they arrived so we would anticipate that
there would be some revisions and
substitutions to that list as we go
through the biennium
so that's item number one
our second priority is for
forest and lands facilities
this request addresses again deferred
maintenance facility upgrades and fire
safety improvements at five of the
division of forest and lands facilities
the most prominent in that group is the
state forest nursery in bosquen
you just heard the commissioner tell you
that the demand
for the nursery for their seedlings has
gone up significantly
and their program needs some help and
particularly in the
seedling cooler facility seedlings need
to be kept in a refrigerated building
currently we have a
lean-to type building off the existing
main barn
it's got structural problems
so what we would like to do is
replace that lean-to
to the barn with a new refrigerated
facilities refrigerated buildings have
taken huge steps forward so there'll be
a lot of energy savings in it we need
about four thousand square feet of space
uh we would gain back 2000 feet in the
barn which then can be repurposed for
seedling sorting and shipping so it'll
be a big
gain there
the other areas where we
are asking for funds for forests and
lands our fox forest urban forestry
center north country resource center in
lancaster and shiling forest in
peterborough
our third request uh it
is a big and important one to us it's
the canon mountain tramway replacement
of
that item number three and item number
four ideally we would do as a pair but
we broke them out in case
the funding could only come at us and
bunches but the situation is that the
cannon mountain aerial tramway is
reaching the end of its service life
the one that we are operating with now
the tramway aerial lift is important
because not only is it a ski lift in the
winter time supplementing on weekends
the busiest weekends that will
supplement the skiers that can come up
on the regular lifts but through the
spring and fall it's a major tourist
attraction in the white mountain area
and
it takes in
about a hundred thousand riders in a
season
recently brought in 1.8 million dollars
in
ticket sales and associated retail sales
so it's important to us from that point
of view but also
we feel that it does attract tourists to
the area and helps all the other
businesses in the north country
now the the company we've been working
with on maintaining the tramway is the
doppelmeyer company
and they've given us a pretty dire
report
about the current tramway
the tram cars or cabins as i like to
call them are
pretty much just physically worn out
the cabins are supported from the cable
by a carriage which is a steel arm and
those steel arms
they have to
support a lot of weight and and pretty
severe weather conditions they have a
life expectancy we're within three years
of the life expectancy of our carriage
arms
the uh the gearboxes
uh and the motors that run the whole
assembly
are
essentially obsolete the company that
provided them for us is no longer in
business so
replacing them in kind is not a
possibility for us
and
the
elect electronic controls that operate
the system
they were put in in the late 70s and
they run on floppy disks
so
we're in a situation where we're really
pushing the lifetime
there is that safety concern about the
arms in a new hampshire tramway safety
board has to certify us every year for
safety and at some point they may not be
able to do that so we'd like to be well
so uh the the fourth request which ties
into this is renovation of the the two
lodges that serve the tramway the valley
station at the base where passengers
come in get oriented buy their tickets
and get on
and the mountain station on the summit
which receives passengers
last majorly renovated in the 1980s when
the new tramway opened up
there have been some small renovations
since then but basically
uh it's looking pretty old
and charitably you could call us retro
uh unchartedly you could say we're
shabby
it's it's that situation this there's
three aspects to what we need to do to
these buildings
one of them is the exterior envelope we
need upgrades there
fortunately with the roofing funds we
have the roofs under control but the
siding the windows the exterior trim and
the doors those are all parts of these
buildings that need to be repaired
and upgraded
we have a life safety concern in these
buildings
because
they actually both stretch back to the
1930s for the first tramway and they had
been renovated and added on to
the state fire marshal and their annual
inspections have pointed out to us that
it's time to really get the egress roots
clearly defined the fire separation
walls up to snuff we need to do that
that work too so we have the exterior
envelope the interior
renovations for presentation to the
public and life safety
we'd love to do this together with the
tramway project and have a complete
renovated tramway to present to the
public
finally
our fifth item
was not on our original capital budget
request but we have added it at the
request of the mount washington advisory
commission the commission has been
working on a master plan for the summit
of mount washington
we know that use of the summit has been
going up
and planning for it it's become apparent
to make good decisions about planning
for that we need some real solid
information so we're looking for an
assessment that includes environmental
concerns and infrastructure concerns
the infrastructure ranges from water
supply at the summit
to the building the space that we have
on the summit do we have enough shelter
to protect people in a severe weather
situation
which happens frequently and
unexpectedly on the top of mount
washington can we shelter everybody we
brought to the summit
what about communications facilities on
the summit it's a major communication
site
and there's a there's commercial users
up there there are more commercial users
that would like to be there but there's
also public safety users
there's the fbi in this homeland
security and and they perfor provide
real functions for public safety
so
we need a coordinated look at that
and all of that we hope would provide a
foundation for future development plans
considerations of the summit's carrying
capacity and strategies
for ecosystem conservation after all
it's a it's an alpine ecosystem
with certain fragility that we should be
paying attention to
so let's
quick review of our five items
and uh i will try to answer any
okay
uh yeah i have a
quick question hopefully uh from first i
want to make sure that i'm understanding
correctly it sounds like with the
tramway particularly
coming to the end of its useful life
this isn't something you can be able to
maintain your way through i mean we
can't just give you a roll of duct tape
and say fix it and you're good for
another five years
that it sounds like
replace it or end it
is that
correct i think that's the situation
that we're in
it's gonna we have to be extremely
careful of course with something like
this transporting the public
so uh there's going to come a time when
we have to say no
the risk has gotten too great and unless
you can make major changes we have to
stop this and it would just be out of
service at that point
so i correct to say that
your requests three and four go hand in
hand that if if you don't get number
three
number four becomes
fairly uh useless because you don't need
to maintain the buildings if you don't
have a tram i just want to assure you we
take the money if you would give it to
us
we could do the renovations but as you
say if we can't go on with the tramway a
major point of it
is taken away
i would like to add that at least the
base building is part of our summer and
fall visitor experience even if they
don't ride the tram so there's bathrooms
there's a
shop a gift shop there's concessions
so i would want to consider
the the maintenance of that
piece of this regardless of what happens
with the tram okay and
now about the usage of the tram you you
mentioned that it has fairly impressive
ticket sales of over well over a million
dollars
who uses the tram is it is it simply is
it is it tourists that come into the
state is it new hampshire residents is
it skiers uh
hikers can you go into that a little bit
i'll touch on that and then if i missed
something i would invite our parks
director phil bryce who is here and has
put a lot of
mental capacity to these questions over
the last few months um
in the winter of course it's our skiers
who um who value the tram but that is is
canon mountain could operate without the
tram in the winter that's the reality um
the tram really serves as a um as a
tourism um
site for summer and fall there are bus
groups that go on the tram the tram is
not like a gondola or a lift right you
can put a group of people on we have
somebody in the tram who describes what
you're looking at it's a it's a visitor
experience and one that uh the area
businesses hotels restaurants direct
people to
in this process we've talked to chambers
of commerce for example
that say that you know this is a feature
that they that they point their visitors
um to
especially since the old man
on the mountain collapsed sadly
this has become
a destination that people um continue to
want to see we have the old man viewing
area there um and so when we talk to
chambers of commerce who are directing
tourists from all over the world to
franconia notch state park this is one
of the things that they do um and so we
have evidence from from the chambers
that that this would be um a very uh
missed experience that they have to
offer their their guests and visitors um
phil do you have any other points that
you would want to include in this
question
yeah why don't you move up to the table
please
okay
state um is ranked
number two number 10
in the top 10 parks in the u.s
we see visitors from all over the world
people up there go through the
bloom for example i've been up there and
there was all kinds of language being
spoken by the people that were visiting
so
of course we get a lot of people from
massachusetts to come up in different
tony notch but people who visit that
site particularly with bus tours
thank you
any other questions representative
thank you um
looking at your funding detail on the
tramway and
we heard this all two years ago with
in the capital budget um but you're
indicating that it's 100
federally funded
um in your funding detail
um is that a true statement and if so
where do the funds come from and if it's
not true what is the funding detail
thank you so over the last two years as
we've been putting together our capital
requests along with various arpa
requests that went through gopher um
we we have realized that there are
several buckets of money and
conversations that are happening about
those buckets that we're not necessarily
privy to so at one point
we were
listing the the federal uh category
thinking that arpa would be an
opportunity we have since revised and
what we passed out today is the revision
of the five priorities that um that inc
that now
it should have just been passed out
before we spoke
um
i will get you a copy because everyone
else has one um but uh we've we've since
been advised to change that so instead
of listing it under federal we've been
told to put it under our capital our
commissioner i i'm curious about the
your revenue 1.8 million
and that's just for the tram yes sir and
that supports a lot of our other state
parks because we are operationally
self-funded
so the um
people pay a fee to ride the tram and it
totals 1.8 million a year
yes
that's pretty impressive associated
retail sales food t-shirts
associated retail sales also
oh like i buy a t-shirt with a picture
of the tram i don't know if that's a
thing
could be
yeah
the question here is is it opera
eligible
is it arpa eligible i don't know if
we're in a position to make that
determination
we present things to gopher and we have
been over the last year and then they
they discern if if it's arpa eligible or
not
okay
i would suggest you talk to the
governor's budget director
and the governor about that because i
know that outdoor recreation is part of
arpa
and
that would be a better use
for arpa funds than some of the other
things that i've seen um and that's
graham speaking not necessarily the
legislature but
it will be a hard sell to get
you know 20 million dollars plus
in a capital budget of 125
plus or minus
for tramway
okay
we can certainly have a discussion and
i'll have discussions with gopher um
very soon thank you about that thank you
james i just had one question is for the
tram would that be completed in that one
bucket of money and during that time
frame or is this a partial phase for the
uh it's not the kind of thing we can do
in phases so it'll be trying to do the
whole thing as quickly as possible and
we think we can do it uh
just one more because we have time
um
the state nursery is that self-funded
that's not is it
we have our state forester with us today
mr arlinghaus uh patrick hackley is here
and he can speak to that hi i'm patrick
hackley i'm the director of division
we've been nip and tuck over the years
but
you know the last few years we've had an
excellent
return on what investment we have there
we haven't made any major investments in
quite some time
the
nursery was
came into existence in 1910
and i can show you some of the equipment
that dates almost close to that in the
barn itself
but
yeah
it's self-supporting and
been doing very well
i'd love to see that equipment for a
we are now remarkably on schedule
um i'd like to invite the new hampshire
liquor commission
up next
just waiting one more minute so we can
be
good morning good morning how are you
i'm joe mallock i'm the chairman of the
new hampshire liquor commission
and with us is our cfo tina demers
and we're here to present to you very
brief capital budget
uh requests
tina will walk you through them
good morning good morning you'll see on
page one we have a summary of our
request we have six requests that are a
hundred percent liquor funded for a
total of twelve million dollars
if you go to page two the first request
is for our hampton north and south new
stores this is additional funding to
construct
two new twenty thousand square foot
retail outlets on i-95 in hampton we put
an original request for 14 million
dollars in the fy 1819 budget and based
on the current rates uh provided by dpw
we've requested to increase the funding
by almost 7.5 million
currently
we're working on existing title and use
restrictions in advance of putting out
an rfp to sell the properties and on
june 17th we were advised that
using the use restrictions could
potentially be completed within the next
90 days so hopefully we will be able to
on the next page is our headquarters
life safety improvements
our concord headquarters facility is 58
years old and it needs a few life safety
improvements
there's a roof replacement for a section
of the roof that was done in 2017 but it
wasn't done appropriately and we need to
replace that section
replacement of warehouse bay fire doors
that were identified during a fire
marshal inspection
building security and door access
controls that are past their useful life
and are no longer supported so that's
our key access systems to get into the
building
and then additional funds for our
parking lot project which was originally
funded to expand and repave the parking
lot but it's turned into a bigger issue
with sewer lines catch basins and an
infrastructure repair underneath the
parking lot and then having to repave
item number three is our keen outlet
roof replacement the keen store was
built in 2005 and the roof is now
leaking and needs to be replaced the
original roof was not properly installed
by the original installer and that's a
on the next page number four
it's emergency funds
the liquor commission maintains 10
state-owned properties that range in the
age from 1964 to 2018.
so this request is to fund unexpected
emergencies for the state-owned
properties
over the last several years we've had a
few issues such as sewer repairs hvac
systems and roof leaks and as an
enterprise fund this would allow the
item number five our computer software
posd 365. we're in the process of
replacing all point-of-sale hardware and
software and back-office computer
systems
and this request is supplemental funds
for enhancements or changes to the
system and possibly additional equipment
that might
be needed
after we go live
this could give us the opportunity to
implement enhancements that it can and
could improve efficiencies and increase
revenues
and then our last
request is to renovate a section of our
warehouse
we're looking to renovate 2200 square
feet of the current warehouse space to
put in multiple office spaces to allow
for workspaces to be safely distanced
and another conference room
and that completes all of our requests
representative
um item three on the roof replacement
what kind of guarantee did we get
when we built that building
it's less than 20 years and it wasn't
installed properly
do we have the option to go back to
whomever built it to do the repairs
gratis
unfortunately um
the keen request
we're on number four
uh no that that replacement was done
that building was built a long time ago
and
there's no there's nothing i'm talking
keen number three you said 2005. yeah
it's less than 20 years there's no
recourse from what we can find uh andy
davis has done some research our real
estate person has done some research on
it
i'm not even sure that the builder is
still in business who built it at that
time
okay uh just a a quick question you have
uh with the new hampton north and south
stores uh when are they going to come
online what are they going to open
uh well hampton north and south will be
under an rfp that we're waiting to put
out
there's been some discussion about some
usable land northbound and southbound so
we've worked with des
we worked within
we've worked with the town of hampton
we did just have a meeting last week as
tina had spoken to
as soon as the rfp goes out
those properties will be sold we had
legislation put in i believe three years
ago that allows us to sell those
properties and use the funds to pay off
liquor commission bonds so the revenues
from that were thought to be as high as
28 million but depending on the usable
property obviously that will affect the
cost i'm at the affect the sale price so
we're waiting to see how much usable
land we actually have to sell
we put out an rfq we had eight vendors
that are interested and obviously they
have they have different
forms of
some of them wanted to put in hotels
there was
some that wanted to put in casinos
obviously we want to we want to have a
liquor store there and something that
resembles what we've done in hooksett
so
as far as the sale price is concerned
and the timing is concerned it's all it
all hinges on that
putting out that actual rfp
okay we're talking sometime
i would think that once the rfp is out
we're probably going to see something
starts at least toward the end of 24. i
can't imagine it would be much further
than that okay because
we've been working on the project for
six years
one of my concerns that this is the
current concern obviously is is is the
manpower and the resources to actually
man these stores and i know
uh right i could imagine that you must
be
experiencing the same thing that many
retailers and including uh the state and
private industries are in trying to
attract especially part-time workers
to fill roles absolutely but if this is
far enough out where
i would assume that the current
shortage of of labor will hopefully have
been
eradicated by that point we hope that
changes by the time these new stores
come online currently
we're 150 part-timers down
uh from a field of about
and we're currently 35 full-timers down
from a field of 216.
so we have significant
vacancy like as you as you stated like
any other state agency or any other
private business at this point right
okay
good morning good morning this is on the
same thing the hampton stores in the
handout it says that the original
request was 14 million
in the 1819 budget was that 14 million
granted in that capital budget is this
seven in addition to the 14 it is that's
correct
and we we go off of the numbers that
were given from public works to base our
so you know the questions
thank you very much thank you very much
uh next and this is to begin at 11 25 we
have the department of safety come up at
11 25 so we have
you
hey
it is 11 25 to call the hearing back to
order
and the department of safety and good
morning
good morning sir members of the
committee my name is robert quinn i'm
the commissioner of the department of
safety
i'm joined today with mr steve avoid
director of administration what you're
going to hear is we are going to present
on four capital projects totaling
six million three hundred and fifty
thousand dollars uh the mission of the
department of safety is to continually
enhance the safety security quality of
life of all with professional
collaborative and innovative services
what you will hear in our request is a
common theme to advance technology
the exchange of vital information while
enhancing customer service and
increasing efficiency across the
department and now i'm pleased to
introduce mr lavoy who will go into a
little more detail on our projects
thank you commissioner good morning
everyone
page two is our first request this is
for the dmv the driver licensing system
known as vision
this system is critical to uh
transaction processing at the dmv it
also serves as a financial management
system and it ensures compliance with
all
state and federal real id licensing laws
rules and regulations
this system processes transactions
including driver license records bureau
of hearings activities payment uh and
processing of violations and impacts on
driver records and also plate and decal
inventory
over the course of a fiscal year
approximately 100 million dollars is
processed through the vision system
the server environment that hosts vision
is approaching end of life and must be
replaced and the department has worked
with doit and looked at alternatives and
determined that the most efficient and
cost-effective option is to move the
environment into the cloud and so that's
what this 2.5 million dollar request
would do it would move migrate the
existing physical infrastructure to the
cloud it would also update the existing
back frame framework for microsoft
dynamics crm to microsoft dynamics 365.
so what this does is it leverages proven
technology
which makes our future upgrades easier
and less costly and eliminates the need
for increased support and overhead to
maintain this critical business
capability
the second project that we have is on
page three and page four and this is to
update the state message platform this
falls under the division of state police
the state message platform passes
criminal justice information between all
areas of the criminal justice system
both at the federal level and at the
state and local level
it's really utilized and impacted by all
folks federal state local and county law
enforcement if you look on page four
it's a good graphical representation of
how the switch works and the impact
the platform itself is in the center and
you can see there's inbound and outbound
queries from the fbi through the
national instant criminal background
check system as well as the national sex
offender registry and you can also see
that there's statewide data that's being
passed through the switch as well that's
through the division of state police
motor vehicles the department of
corrections the court system and local
and county law enforcement
the switch itself is a combination
primarily hardware but there's a strong
software component and
both of those need to be replaced to
ensure that this data is flowing
appropriately
page five is our third request
this is to update the document scanning
equipment that the dmv currently
utilizes to record physical copies of
documents that are received from across
the state
if you see on page six
we're currently utilizing microfilm
technology to archive these documents
these include registrations titles
purchase and sale agreements all the
documents to support transactions that
are being processed at the locals at
municipalities and then also at dmv
substations
the equipment is
it's old technology the equipment itself
is breaking down regularly it's
challenging to find individuals who can
even service the equipment we're also
having trouble finding options for
film processing so
this one million dollar request would
allow the department to convert to
digital scanning
the
there might be some document indexing
abilities to include in that request the
scanning equipment would certainly be at
the department of safety but there may
be an opportunity to expand this to the
local level as well since a lot of the
documents are generated and obtained
there
and then on page seven is our fourth
request
this is to improve the technology of the
state police helicopter this is a 1.5
million dollar request
to update a lot of the technology
including the flir camera and mapping
software which was originally installed
in 2016 and is approaching its end of
life
the helicopter is utilized for search
and rescue operations
to special event responses swat calls
and also major disaster scene and storm
damage assessments
this improvement would fund an update to
the fleer camera and then the augmented
reality mission computer uh you can see
pictures of both of those on page eight
the mission computer is in the uh
cockpit well it shows a picture of the
cockpit on the bottom and then the
mission computer is in the cabin
the mission computer is utilized by the
flight terminal operator to help guide
the pilot and
when providing the emergency response
activities as as needed
we'd also use this funding to integrate
that system with the state's current
video management system to enable
real-time monitoring of criminal
situations as they're developing and
then there'd also be some miscellaneous
flight equipment upgrades including
white phosphorus night vision goggles
and the related helmets
and so page nine shows a summary of our
four projects as the commissioner
mentioned they're all technology focused
um they're based on ensuring that we
continue to deliver
public safety services across the state
in an efficient and effective manner
and they're really critical to
maintaining the existing levels of
okay i'd like to open up for questions
and my first question is
we as far as the helicopter goes where
we're talking about
technological improvements to it but
what's the status of the actual
helicopter it's a bell 407
is the helicopter as far as when was
that purchase and what's the useful life
remaining on that piece of equipment
so
i can't give you the exact years but i
had that question i asked that question
recently and it's based on
hours on the engine
and it's based on any
rust issues or infrastructure issues
that they're seeing when they do the
inspection right now the the helicopter
you know meets the standards you know
we've had these discussions internally
what's next what's the plan we're not
there now i'm looking at all options on
replacement
these investments
could be utilized in the event that say
we lease the next helicopter so
these investments could be transferred
if we went in another direction but
right now i think we're good for several
years
i will say that uh the gentleman that we
have in the state police
business
um business and projects unit
is a helicopter pilot was a helicopter
pilot extensive career and he's um
paying close attention to this and we're
we're really looking at uh looking at
um
commission
oh sorry
thank you
you heard me mention earlier that in
some cases
systems get you know the the software
company stops supporting the on-premise
version
so as it relates to the first request
that's also a factor so this this
version that
dmv is now running
will no longer exist or be supported so
that's another
to me a very significant driver for that
project it's not a nice to have it's an
absolute must-have project for dmv
and um i would also say the dmv has
distinguished themselves nationally
because most of these
types of projects are kind of disastrous
in terms of business operations and the
citizen service impacts involved and dmv
has done a great job of
actually keeping that system running
solidly and
and providing you know with limited
resources really good customer service
so
one of the questions that i'm sure will
be asked and you don't need to answer it
today is how did you determine
on that it was 19 highway or 24
turnpike on a different one those issues
become very important as we look at the
road toll
declining over the years
you don't need to answer it today but if
these
projects make the cut with the governor
i'm sure that the legislature will ask
them
because
every dollar that goes into something
like that is is less that goes on to our
roads and bridges
along those same lines
does the turnpike or highway funding
impact what some of these are labeled as
uh no no the cost of collections is
separate from
those funding mixes
however costs of collections comes
directly off the top of the road toll
correct it's all
to your point uh representative it's all
it's all related um and and our approach
has always been um
we're less concerned about the the
source of funding and more concerned
about the funding itself
so those
percentages are
we're happy to revisit those if they're
okay
that's any other further questions thank
you very much
thank you
uh the hearing uh will stand in recess
now on for lunch break and we will
you
it is now 1pm and i'd like to reconvene
the governor capital budget hearing and
i would like to invite the department of
afternoon commissioner
good afternoon sir and honorable members
of the committee i hope you had a very
satisfying lunch because that'll predict
how this conversation goes
looks pretty good out there
helen hanks for the record commissioner
of the department of corrections to my
right is jonathan hanson our agency's
director of administration
thank you for the opportunity to talk
about the corrections department asks on
the capital budget side
so before you have a modified
presentation um trying to streamline our
requests uh differently than what we
remitted
what feels like a long time ago but i
guess it wasn't
and you'll see seven priorities
and as the governor kicked off this
morning
it has been really clear i'm rounding
out my 19th year with the department in
october october 3rd if you want to send
me a gift but
what's been really clear is the
commissioner of the department and going
through
our public works projects and the
infrastructure at the new hampshire
state prison for men is that facility is
not going to last i have worked with
john and seeing things i didn't think
were plausible or possible as far as as
electrical as far as cement erosion as
far as where water will always go
and
that
we as a state really needs to understand
how to move forward and how to work on
uh developing a facility that both is
staffing efficient but as well as
structurally sound and we're trying to
in this ask in this budget
ask for the things that we need
before we get to a new facility
and i hope that you'll find that with us
today
so you'll see a preliminary study of a
new facility for men in concord and we
want to include in there also financial
opportunities that we should be
considering as a state and we've come up
with 2.5 million and i can have john
talk to that as we move forward the
second is our kitchen renovation project
for members of the committee who have
been here before and new members
working with health and human services
our kitchen at the new hampshire state
prison for men
and pictures are worth a thousand words
so we'll go through those as well
needs a renovation and
and was funded for it but as most
projects has have moved forward we need
more money to get the job done
what's new this year number three is our
radio system upgrade
we are still on an analog based system
and the fcc some time ago as early as i
think 2014 or 15 told agencies to switch
to a digital system and this system is
our main communication path for security
it needs a major upgrade
we have to continue to replace steam
traps and lines and we need additional
funding for the project that was
previously authorized in number four the
same is true in number five and then uh
in six as well as seven our security
defense detection being our primary and
most outward facing security control and
then the construction uh training center
for building trades is targeted for
women who are incarcerated and we need
additional money to finish that project
and be
collaborative with our new hampshire
legal assistance partners in moving
equity forward for women who are
incarcerated so if we go to page two we
start to show you some pictures of our
new hampshire state
prison for men
that
facility if you haven't have the luxury
of walking through it i'd be happy to
take you through that anytime and let
you back out
is a campus style infrastructure
it is not efficient from a staffing
model it causes challenges in having to
have numerous movements to control
classifications
and the staffing complement to go with
that
so even in the second picture on that
slide you can see how inefficient having
a wide open space is
to travel to housing units and so on and
so forth
what's not gleaned here is just the age
of the buildings and john if you could
speak to the differing ages i think that
will help people listening to the
presentation
sure
so the men's prison in concord was built
in 1878. that's the new prison it was
moved up from tremont street that one
was the older prison
1878 that building was built before
there was electricity so you can imagine
some of the challenges we had to rewire
that um actually the 1878 portions of
that facility are in pretty good shape
the additions that were put on in 1980
to 1983 were the major additions those
were behind
the existing men's facility and if
you've been up there you know that's in
between the women's and the men's that
side hill that they cut into
um
those areas are having some serious
challenges structurally and as ted knows
and some of his staff have gone out
there with me to see some things that
are unique in that we've had um
a we have a large ramp that is actually
a roof a very unique design and that
goes over the kitchen area we'll talk
about that in a little bit but those
challenges that we have within that
newer section are pretty extensive and
structurally we're having some serious
issues we're also looking at some things
like and we'll talk about this later too
with the
with the kitchen renovation coming into
the yard area which you see in some of
those photographs on the first slide
that yard area actually has
some coal
pockets and things that back in the day
when the big huge boilers were there
they trucked in coal and dumped by train
into the ground and then it was
conveyored into these
giant boilers
when they tore down those industry
buildings in between in 1980
they still left some
caverns and voids and those are areas
that we want to expand out in the
kitchen area so we're going to be
talking about some potential pilings or
at least some
unique base structuring for that
for the footings for that for that
building
so those are some of the challenges
we're having on that area and as the
commissioner indicated
to do the this as the governor mentioned
this morning as well to determine that
feasibility and the preliminary
engineering costs
and the cost estimates to build
something new are really what we're
looking for with this first item now
versus the full monty and asking for the
entire
as we go along too as part of that
engineering study and as as we've talked
a few of us about that funding there are
some unique funding opportunities that
i'm
i'm hoping that the legislature and you
folks will look at
obviously at least revenue bonds are
being used around around the country for
this type of facility versus a general
obligation bond that is a different way
to fund the facility
there is a multitude of different ways
and that is part of the study we really
need to flesh out if that's a
possibility to do this because
as the governor mentioned this morning
uh
350 million dollars
right now would be the minimum to build
the size of the facility we need the the
federal prison in uh berlin
was all in i think it was 430 430
million in 2012. of course it's bigger
but that is a modern facility and that's
what the type of facility we believe we
need to to build
there's also some issues that we need to
flesh out on this preliminary design as
far as location and utilities we
need maximum utilities at this facility
we use over a million gallons of water a
day thankfully from the city of concord
we have some of the largest power feeds
in the city of concord
i believe we're either par or second to
concord hospital
and the size of facility as as you say
in your in your
um capital budget planning we really
need to look at anticipated 50-year life
of that facility minimum so we need to
really determine down the road what that
would be and as helen indicated there's
a multitude of different designs you
know the typical prison designs going
back many many years you know your
radial designs courtyard designs the
telephone pole design and the campus
design
and everything we design here is it
needs to be to reduce recidivism
and as they say in some of the best
prisons in the in the world right now
and hauled in norway you know being in
prison is the punishment the design
so as you can see on page three and then
continued on page four we tried to take
some pictures of
both the what i call the apartment
complex style
general population housing units um i
think it's important as you look at
three these were designed for
approximately 120 people 120 people and
then um in 2009 when we shut down the
lakes region facility due to funding and
economics now we house 240 people
so it's no surprise we had to replace
those bathrooms and it's no surprise
that these infrastructures of
are running out of their architectural
on page four you'll see against that
concrete erosion on the uh
picture on page four to the right of
your slide
that actually um that concrete holds in
a fenced barrier that questionably i'm
not even sure how we would re-secure it
if it falls down
it's very some very strange things
as you go to slide five we try to show
you some of the mechanicals and
electrical uh situations within the
institution
and i will say through my time as
commissioner admin services you've been
an amazing partner when uh we've had
ground lines spliced underground that i
didn't even know were there transformers
explode that you we had a hard time
finding a new one
so again we're trying to get hold of the
situation in a more timely manner
and then moving to page six we talk
about the kitchen renovation continue to
show you the state of the kitchen
we do have these structures in the
ceiling to direct and control water
coming in through the ramped ceiling
that was designed
to go into drains in the floor and
we continue to be monitored by our
partners at health and human services
and do our own monitoring to make sure
that the food being delivered does not
sicken anyone but it does need to be
finished and we need more money to
accomplish that
page seven we continue to show you
pictures of the existing kitchen
and yes there are tarps behind those
pots again to control water
and water access while we're cooking
on page 8 we show you the radio system
upgrade the new project in this proposal
that is a picture
on the left side of the page
of
peter in the attic it is not up to
current standard and needs to be up to
current standard and on the spec
picture this literally the number of
radios just at the men's prison as a
representation of our need and it's not
just our security staff that use it as a
communication tool it's our group two
correctional line personnel that use
that as well because they are
independent and doing their group work
and other healthcare work throughout the
institution do you want to speak more to
the
thank you commissioner so the radio
system we've looked at many different
ways um
it's a and as the radio folks with
department of safety were here earlier
today would tell you um
that
that's the the older radio systems vhf
155 megahertz systems
um
doesn't always penetrate through the
concrete um it is the type of system
that's not totally reliable it can be
monitored by anyone
it can also be interfered now by people
which has been happening over the last
year or two we'll be in the middle of
something somebody
various behavior outside the facility or
somewhere we can't pinpoint has grabbed
a radio with that frequency and is
holding the mic while we're saying
get people to shoot as soon as
and then we've got nothing and as soon
as possible as soon as next week
what's the emergency we also can
identify who's calling on the radio we
have no idea they could be in a 20 mile
radius because that
that wattage on that radio is that
strong in some cases they could be way
outside the facility
the other thing too is that the prison
runs on communication
that
is a system where we cannot bring cell
phones smartphones those things inside
the facility and text somebody oh i
think this inmate's gonna have a problem
that that doesn't happen in their prison
environment so that is the first line of
communication for safety within a prison
facility it's very unique
um
and the other problem we have beyond
that is not only the older systems the
handheld but the older systems in the
mobile units so we leave shelburne uh
sorry we leave berlin in a uh in a
van transport van as we call it with
resident inmates in the back and there
is a myriad of dead spots as you go
through shelburne as you go back down
across
into
franconia and down the line we can't get
emergency signals out and that's
very serious so what's happened is a lot
of our ceos are actually grabbing their
own cell phones and making calls it's
just not the professional way to do that
and this would include something like
that
so as we go to page nine we continue to
show the steam lines and traps that
continue need to be replaced and this is
additional money to see that project
through from the last cycle
it's just more rusty than it was the
last time you saw this photo
on page 10 we continue to show you the
sewer line grinder that is
is that on the street north state street
yeah i can explain a little bit yeah so
this is my least favorite conversation
yeah this
this is the sewer grinder aka known as
the muffin monster that is the brand
manufacturer for that product
this was something we're working
hand-in-hand with the city on we need to
get our line away from their main line
so we don't keep sending
trash all the way down to
hall street where the wastewater
treatment plant is and that is a direct
line down along the side of merrimack
river and they call us on a regular
basis and say
we've got things that look like they
came from your place i get to go look at
them sometimes and they have the
inmate's name on them so yes that came
from us they do flush things down so
what we're doing is bringing that
offline the reason for the more money
and the reason we're here for the more
money is that it will
according to our latest estimates come
directly through our parking lot at the
men's prison and there will be building
built that's larger that we expected to
put the auger and the muffin monster in
to pull that trash out so to get the
proper place instead of sending it down
down holster
thank you
i have been asked could we stop
individuals from putting things into the
plumbing and unfortunately not with the
number of beds with we don't have the
ability to monitor that much pipage
so moving on to page 11 it continues to
upgrade our security and perimeter
detection system again this is to see
that project to completion for all the
same reasons we asked for last year
it is a i will use the term hodgepodge
of different materials fencing metal
fencing brick
you name it it is part of our secure
perimeter and it is important to make
sure that secure perimeter functions the
way a prison secure
perimeter functions with wave detection
and all all the other items necessary
especially
with our staffing we need those alarms
to actually be triggered because there
is a threat there and not to be
triggered because there's an error
because of the age of the system we want
to use our staff efficiently and we
don't want anyone becoming complacent
because the system doesn't work
effectively and they say oh that's just
an error
so we just need to continue to finish
that project and see it to its
conclusion
and then on page 12
this is again to create parity in our
vocational programs between women who
are incarcerated and men who are
incarcerated and this is the additional
money to see that
what is uh strife to be planned to be a
building trades program for women to
help build their job skills and reduce
recidivism and and help people move on
to employment which will ultimately help
our employers in new hampshire with
viable employees
anything you would like to add john
the only
time thank you
the only thing with the the women's
design we came in we thought we had had
plenty of money to do that project and
we didn't possibly have that much money
in 2018 dollars but when those estimates
came in they came way up high and you'll
also see in the picture
if you were here last time you saw we
wanted it inside the secure perimeter
that location was not conducive to where
the utilities were so we saved some
money by moving it outside the perimeter
into a control fence area so that we
could connect the utilities and as it
turned out
that would cost us more money in the
long run to connect to everything from
that point back to the sewer line the
electrical lines and the building
expanded because we added some more
trades to be uh in the training of the
so with that we certainly appreciate any
questions or comments
thank you very much
my first question is relates to
the men's prison
and i mean up here we have two branches
of government represented the executive
and and the
legislature what role
would the judicial play in this if uh
a new prison is not built at what point
do they step in and say
it is unsatisfactory we need this x y
and z to happen have there been any sort
of discussions with the judiciary on
that or
is that something you would anticipate
might be coming in the future
thank you for that question i think
the track record of the agency has
already demonstrated those things to
come to fruition
that includes the holiday court order in
which we were ordered to construct a
residential treatment unit and rather
than taking a hold of it and doing it
ourselves we could have created a
residential treatment unit without
spending approximately 5 million dollars
on a 40 bed unit
in addition to that there was a stay on
the litigation with regard to the
women's prison because the state funded
the 52 million dollar women's prison
facility
we're always better served to be ahead
of it before we're ordered to do it the
way an advocacy group wants us to do it
it doesn't mean we won't design it
effectively as corrections professionals
and engineers but we want to have our
voice and our experience in it rather
than being ordered into it and there are
other pieces of uh litigation the llama
and consent degree uh lepin is all about
programmatic and rehabilitative programs
that you know if we don't have the
proper infrastructure to deliver then
we're going to be ordered to provide
that infrastructure
so this is our agency saying to the
state we're telling you that
infrastructure is
is is running out of its lifespan
the kitchen in and of itself hhs told us
we need to replace it or we'll have to
shut that thing down and then the secure
psychiatric unit for example we need our
roofs that are funded or we have
partners who have already are already
poised to move forward with litigation
if those roofs are not resolved so we
have a history here and we're trying to
not be litigated to get it done
you mentioned that building a new
facility in the design of which could
improve the efficiencies of
uh with your dispersed dispersing of
security personnel well i know well i
realize you don't have the exact design
yet
uh what sort of savings as far as
manpower are we talking about
given the current design in what you
would consider to be an efficient design
that would be forthcoming
i appreciate the question but i think
it's premature in that we're already
currently understaffed in the current
fiscal layout um and we'd we would have
to see it designed and likely the
existing staff using it most effectively
while continuing to recruit to fill the
vacancies we have today right but i
think the question more goes to under
this facility ideally you would have x
number of people
and the new facility you could you could
staff it with
you know something x minus
a certain factor certainly but we don't
have a design yet and in addition to
although we've seen a population decline
while we go through this study we have
to understand what that pattern of
incarceration and recidivism is to
forecast the proper number of beds
so there's a lot of different variables
having gone through it with the women's
prison that i can certainly dive into
deeply but you probably don't want me to
do that today okay thank you thank you
representative
um
thank you commissioner
um and looking at
the study
why are we only looking at concord it is
my understanding
that when we built the prison in berlin
it was built to be expandable
why are we not at least exploring that
as part of this option rather than
saying it's got to be in conquered
a rep graham i think that's a great
question
we could we certainly would include that
in a feasibility study we've always
balanced the actual availability of
personnel
so for example if we moved all of our
men's prison operations to berlin would
there be enough employees actually to
fulfill the obligation
and we even went through that balanced
conversation when we were going to build
the women's prison so i think it's a
great question and we'll include
what kind of expansion effort we can
engage in up there but i do think we
balance that we are a
broad geographic state even though we're
small and we need that employee cadre as
well
um i have a couple of high
um i have a couple of questions one how
many guests do you currently have
in your various facilities
well
we have
1884 people in our prison facilities and
transitional housing facilities today we
have just under 6 000 under supervision
on probation and parole so how so how
big is the men's prison if i said that
you hey how big is the men's prison in
concord
what would you say so the
so the current capacity is 1380
which we've exceeded by putting bunk
beds in places designed to be day rooms
um and then rooms that were designed to
be six person rooms we converted those
to eight person rooms as far back as
2009 but it's about it's about 1380 how
big is the women's prison
that has 227 beds
four 224.
okay he corrected me my you're close
yeah
how big is berlin
that yeah it's designed for 500 we've
had it as high as 630
again back when the population was high
in 2010 2011 uh put bunk beds in one of
the gymnasiums
oh great but it's designed for 500. yes
like you wouldn't want more than 500. no
and i believe our account there is 535
so we still have more than it's designed
for
do you have a sense that your um
population is i know a lot of this is
determined by legislation but
your population is likely to keep
rising or slowing or
so we've seen approximately a 28
decline in the incarcerated population
over the last 15 years so even though we
had a spike in 2010 2011
pre-covered this state through the
implementation of drug court and other
diversion and intervention
approaches has reduced the incarceration
rate and when i say that i mean new
crime admission rate as well as
violation rates
so we are actually in a good place at
this point um it would be hard to
predict predict what comes each year
after year but it's a 28 decline over
the last 15 years and you think that's
um
[Music]
i don't know what the right word is
apples to apples sort of i mean i know
you can't really compare things but like
adjusted for
i don't know population differences or
you think a lot of that's attributable
to the to the way we do corrections
i think it's attributable to the things
we've done both at the local level to
provide access to treatment services
specifically substance use disorder
treatment
changes that the judiciary is engaged in
to create specialty courts and i also
think that judges are
you know they take the action very
seriously balancing punishment and uh
diversion when it's appropriate
if if you were full today in the three
facilities
how
how bad would your staffing be like how
low would we be
so last july that's a great question i
was able to shut down the second floor
of hancock building that's 196 beds that
means there were 14 posts we didn't have
to fill and then this year we were able
to shut down one of the 56 bed c3
women's units so that's five positions
we didn't need to fill if we have to
open those because we were already
understaffed meaning the proper number
of
positions we're not filled to function
at the capacity we are today
again i i would be asking for other
resources within the state to continue
to run our operations and then to follow
up on that uh in terms of resources you
have today and i know there are a lot of
triage techniques right and related to
overtime and whatnot but
comfortably speaking how many more
correction officers would you need to be
at an appropriate staffing level for
today
for today with the population we have
today yeah
and this doesn't
so we have a hundred and
eighty two security vacancies i would
need them all filled and then looking at
the 2012 lba audit of our security posts
i would be coming back asking for more
positions to create relief factor which
we don't have in our staffing regiment
one of the follow-up question
uh
the
the men's prison and the renovation for
the kitchen that that's not in either or
you need both because of the priority of
these so it's not someone who couldn't
think well we're going to build a new
prison anyway so why do we need a new
kitchen you need the kitchen
and i needed the kitchen like six years
ago right yeah okay thank you
good thank you very much
uh next on the agenda uh which will
begin in three minutes is the police
standards and training councils like to
invite them up
if you weren't here this morning we the
schedule is such that the notice
provisions where we have to start at the
exact time of your
time so
okay like to welcome the police
standards and training council
gentlemen the floor is yours
thank you so much
uh for the record my name is john skipa
i'm the director of new hampshire police
standards and training and sitting to my
right is max schultz he is the assistant
director
we're here today to talk about
two
capital improvement projects for your
consideration
while i've handed my full text out to
the members of this committee
i'd like to just kind of jump right to
presently
we are experiencing a
space shortage
to a degree that it impacts our ability
to deliver
both recruit training and in-service
training for all new hampshire law
enforcement officers in the state of new
hampshire
specifically we are asking for your
consideration for two projects
the first project
is
allowing us or will allow us to move
a
training simulator from
two classrooms
to an out building that already exists
so that we can reclaim those two
classrooms
uh back in uh 2000
i think it was 2014 2013 i'm sorry
we were fortunate enough to uh obtain
a device called a virtra
which is a 360
uh
training device that
is very very low cost very safe and it
helps officers uh train and practice and
de-escalation techniques and firearms
techniques
uh that device
hovered right around 350 thousand
dollars
for us to purchase we were able to
exercise a grant to purchase that
i think the the purchase came uh with
the realization that the device had to
be put somewhere in the building
and so the decision was made to
use two classrooms that are next to each
other
and reconfigure that classroom to hold
this device in so that it can be used
the device is used about 25 percent of
our hope is that we would be able to
take that device
uh move it out of the main building into
an existing
garage really and then reclaim that
classroom space which is desperately
needed
the second project would be to take an
existing
what we call a break room uh back in the
old days when i went through the police
academy this was our uh tactical
training center uh the room was probably
about half the size of this room
and uh because of additions that came
after the initial construction
this space
really now is kind of used as a bit of a
break room
and kind of a staging area for scenario
training but otherwise it's a
significant amount of space that's
wasted
we feel that these two projects
will allow us to in the first instance
reclaim two classrooms that we
desperately need
and then create a third classroom and
some office space again
we think that this is kind of a fiscally
responsible way to do this in that
we're going to remain in the existing
footprint of our building this will not
it's important to recognize that when
the building was first built
we did not have the demand of services
that we're seeing now
those demands
uh have come over time
and you'll see in my remarks that uh the
initial building was built
in
and then an addition in 1986 and then in
1992 the last edition
i think at the time uh
there was not any anticipation that uh
the need for space classroom space was
going to grow the way it did
on top of that our agency has
assumed a number of new duties
over the last two years for a variety of
reasons to include leak and some
legislative initiatives to provide
crisis intervention training to police
officers across the state
and to
create a more robust
misconduct review board
for all of those reasons uh
we feel that it's imperative that we we
try to reclaim this space so that it's
usable
i
with that
i would uh
stand ready for any questions or
concerns any
good afternoon again uh my question is
the garage where the simulator is going
what's that being used for now
so that is one of two garages that we
have out back and the maintenance
department
has uh
kind of turned that into a
catch-all storage facility
we feel very confident that we could
either rent or buy a condex unit
to to use just for the purposes of
storage
we do not use that for
vehicles it's really just it's turned
into over time
kind of the kitchen draw if you would
for police standards and training so
we feel very confident that those items
that we have to retain
uh would fit in a context without a
problem
appreciate it
i have a question so you you operate
essentially you do a full-time police
academy a different a sort of different
curriculum for part-time police officers
and then the
the was it new hampshire corrections
academy these are all done on site
uh that is correct commissioner and um
it's a dumb question but how like how
much of your operation is each of those
is it mostly the
full-time police officers and the other
two are sort of addendums or
so we we serve as the sole source for
recruit training for every single law
enforcement officer in the state of new
hampshire
we are one of the few states that enjoy
the single academy
there are many states in our country
that
have academies across their state and i
can tell you
that it
causes a lot of problems quite frankly
on top of that we are the primary source
for in-service training for all law
enforcement officers to include
all the the state level corrections
on top of that we also run a probation
parole
kind of additive to those academies and
we also provide the part-time police
academy
over the last probably six months we
have seen a significant demand for
academy training because our
our profession right now is seeing a
a just a brutal recruitment and
retention environment
and uh police officers are leaving in
droves here in new hampshire
and across the country quite frankly
we are in order to keep up with the
demand because we don't have enough
classroom space
we are working where we have overlapping
police academies
while we're running
the corrections academy and the
part-time academy
my staff is very unhappy with me right
now
but that's the demand and we're gonna
meet that demand
if we had more space
we would be able to
reduce
the size of classes which would reduce
the the number of instructors per class
and we could move at a pace
that would allow us to keep up with the
attrition rate
that a lot of these communities are
feeling i cannot tell you how many times
i get a call from a chief
saying i got to get my guy in i gotta
get my guy in and we we've maxed out on
the seats we just don't have enough
seats and so we have to kick that that
recruit down the road to the next
available class
so to to speak to uh our priorities
commissioner that the first priority is
recruit training
and uh we devote
probably
i would say around 80 percent of our
resources to deliver that program
and then another 15
to 18 percent on the in service program
although that is going to increase
because because of leak
new hampshire police officers
instead of having eight hours of
in-service training mandated
is rising up to 24 hours
annually of in-service training
for that reason we we need to expand our
in-service training program as well to
meet the needs of all the law
enforcement officers that we have
uh and then finally the uh the part-time
academy
uh really for a variety of reasons we're
seeing that to be the least of of our
uh resource allocation
to to follow up on that you're you're in
a situation right now where demand
significantly exceeds capacity and
you're i mean i don't mean it quite that
way but you are having to occasionally
turn people away and and come back to
the next meeting or
if you were
it is this is the uh uh biggest obstacle
to meeting that demand at the time of
demand
uh classroom space
if it is
is additional classroom space
um and and i'm presuming beyond your
capital budget request even
does it need to be on site i mean i
presume it needs to be on site but i
figured i would ask that
for a variety of reasons we many of
these classes require equipment as part
of the training
all of our staff are located on site
and their ability to access it equipment
and things of that nature training
equipment uh
again uh we we're trying to be
self-sufficient and we did think you
know short term can we address this
problem and in fact we are using
uh the national guard
armory in uh
is it penacook or pembroke pembroke
to deliver cit training because we just
we we just don't have the space
and those cit classes are rolling
uh so
we can handle it in a
kind of a uh
you know if this was
a peak
in our activity we certainly could work
around that you know we have nhti across
the street we could enter into some
agreements with them
to rent space
although we don't have any money in our
budget to do that now
uh but we we certainly could try to
figure something out for the short term
uh i i truly believe that this is not a
short term problem that we're looking at
and in fact
uh
is a problem that's going to be with us
for and not a problem but a challenge
that's in front of us and will be for
for a period of time
so that begs the question then that um
you're reclaiming class from three and
four
and i think project two is a
a fifth classroom functionally
uh to what extent does that meet the
demand or is that only part way there
i i think that gets us
uh
a good
a good way past part-time so it'll
it'll it'll buy us uh a couple of years
i think if it weren't an issue if
i'm going to say words you're not
supposed to say in the legislature if
money weren't an issue
um
is it a sixth classroom or a seventh
classroom where would you need to be if
i if i said you you know i think we can
work something out would it be an
additional one beyond these three
uh commissioner if i understand the
question and money is not a it's very
hypothetical very hypothetically
i would i would uh propose in addition
to our tactical center to create
two very large
uh 150 seat
uh
lecture halls that could actually be
opened up into one big lecture hall
uh and a number of office spaces because
i think that gets us
that covers the academy training right
there we could have very very large
academy classes to keep up with
the demand
and then we would have
in essence we would reclaim two lecture
halls from the existing building that we
could then use for in-service
but that
is
with uh would cost more money uh yes sir
so one last hypothetical and then i'll
shut up um
not hypothetical but the excess demand
or the the
increased demand for lack of a better
word um across the board or is it mostly
among full-time officers like are you
seeing
significant excess demand with
correctional academy and part-time too
or is it
so
i think that's a great question
commissioner right now we are seeing a
significant demand for full-time police
officer training
every single community in our state
through attrition and just difficulty
and recruitment
they're just seeing
a vast number of vacancies
we have to stay on top of that demand we
cannot be the choke point
because these communities and these
agencies are are hiring these good
people we got to get them trained we got
to get them back to the towns and cities
we are
we are ready and willing and able to
take care of the department of
corrections
their classes have traditionally been
very very low
again because of the difficulty in
recruitment
i think this class we have right now we
have 15 uniformed officers and that
the one before that was eight and the
one before that i think was 12
i think so it's very very difficult to
recruit
the the police department the police
departments
are finding candidates very quickly
uh they're hiring them and they're
trying to turn them around as fast as
they can so
uh
again trying to meet all those needs
it's a great challenge we we love it
this is our business uh we just want to
be able to do it so that we're not uh
the choke point
thank you thanks for indulging me thank
you sir
representative
um thank you um
you're talking about a today problem of
classroom and all the rest
assuming that these were approved in the
next capital budget we're talking two to
three years from now before you see
classrooms
um
what are your plans are you just going
to keep muddling along
uh over the next two to three years and
hope that it all evens out at the end of
the next biennium
or or what because it gets to the heart
of the matter of what what do we fund
what do we build
and how soon do we get it done it really
does
i appreciate that question
representative
uh i think it's a today problem that's
not going away
that's how i see this
i've been in new hampshire law
enforcement for just shy of 40 years
and i can tell you that i have never
seen
the vacancy rate that we are seeing
right now
and and
to that end i don't know that that's
going to get corrected any time soon
quite frankly and i think the
this uh the new workforce the younger
folks that we have coming into our
profession
are not seeing it the same way
people like me saw it you know you get
in and you you do your time you click
away i think a lot of these younger
people they do it
they do it for five years ten years and
then they're moving down the road to
something bigger and better and more
exciting
although i can't imagine what else is
more exciting than this right
so i i i agree with you this is a today
problem
uh but i really
i think it's very important to
understand that this is a today problem
that is going to continue into the
future and in the meantime
representative and i think it's a great
question
the major and i are literally
pulling what hair we have left out of
our heads
to try to meet the short-term demands
and again the national guard's been very
helpful to us providing us some learning
space
depending on
some certain legislation that may go
through
that may free up some money for us to
we still need to sit down with nhti and
see if there's any opportunities that we
can leverage over there to help us meet
the immediate demand that we're looking
at right now
uh and again
we're going to have to address even that
immediate demand
we're going to have to try to address
that in the next fiscal year because we
just we didn't plan for it in this
biennium
yes
so just to follow up on the
commissioners and representatives
question
has there been any
space needs studies done to determine
how many you know how many square feet
you might need of classroom space to
solve your problem
uh there is not that's an excellent
question uh again
uh
we are looking at this and the reason we
came to this these decisions to bring
these uh projects forward
i guess like a farmer's
approach of just looking at you know
what we have on deck for people trying
to get into these classes
and and the fact that uh that rate has
not dropped and in fact has increased
also understanding that in the course of
the next three years
we're going to need to triple our uh
in-service
offerings uh because of uh
changes from leak
so we haven't done a a a study per se
we have based these projections really
on what we're seeing now and what we
absolutely know is coming into the
future which is that that increase in
in-service cl
classes and hours
thank you follow up on that yes please
um the device that you're planning to
move to the garage
would moving it to the garage
allow you full use of the device in your
training protocols
all right that's a great question and
yes the so the the virtual as i said
earlier is a very very expensive piece
of equipment in fact part of the
request here is to actually pay the
company to come and do the moving
because it is is so um
it's it's both delicate and it has to be
set up exactly the way it's supposed to
be set up so that it works properly
but that would indeed give us those two
classrooms back
uh which would still be able to use the
device located in the garage
we absolutely could we the uh again part
of the project is to refurbish the
garage so that it is it's not a garage
anymore but a training facility and uh
the other plus to it while it's not a
real problem
uh as you can imagine the virtua
simulates some very chaotic situations
and those chaotic situations are very
loud
and that virtua is right next to our
lecture hall so if we have an in-service
class going on
in the virtua
and they're responding to an active
shooter
at the same time that we're doing
constitutional law in the lecture hall
for the recruits
the recruits get a little bit of both uh
because of the the yelling and screaming
and
the rounds that you can hear going off
we tried to soundproof it as best as
possible but
still a lot of chaos so moving it out to
the garage would certainly eliminate
that problem as well a rock concert next
to a court facility right you couldn't
say it any better than that sir
representative
thank you director uh the question i
have is you have such a workload
and i'm a representative from hampton
and the question has to do with
part-time training do you actually have
any classes now or have you had any
recently
so uh chief hobbs a very good friend of
mine
a very good friend of mine i came up in
the seacoast too
and um
he has been part of a
working group
where we're trying to
land on how we move forward on the
part-time program
and
this was one of the directives given to
me by the governor under uh executive
order 2020-19 which was to look at the
part-time program and re-evaluate it
quite frankly
i
the short answer is yes we're getting
ready to start a part-time class i
reached out to dave and let him know
i think that i'm going to propose some
changes to my counsel and to the
governor
really part-time officers are supposed
to be used the way hampton uses them
and that is to augment
police services right
the unfortunate truth is that there's a
lot of communities that have now used
this program to supplant
uh their their police services
and that is um it's not fair to the
citizens and it's not
fair to the officers that are part-time
and expected to do full-time work uh
oftentimes by themselves and i think
that's we're trying to balance
those two things
so
thank you does this request your budget
request uh support trying to take on
some initiatives with the part-time
program uh yes it does it absolutely
does uh it just creates more space for
us to have those classes
as it stands right now and the other
resource that is
is pretty thin is are the bodies the
trainers right
so um
because of that
lack of depth of resource
i feel that we're probably only going to
be able to hold one part-time academy a
year
as we move forward and and again i'll
i'll try to address those resource needs
as we move forward into the next fiscal
budget
thank you very much
greatly appreciate it thank you very
much
in our final presentation of the
afternoon
good afternoon
nathan white dhhs cfo
excuse me lori weaver deputy
are you ready for us we are ready
i think everyone has the handout uh we
have a a team approach here this
afternoon so you'll find in front of you
um three of our top
priority of our capital projects which
a summary of the the total funds
requested uh broken down into uh general
funds and federal funds
and then we've included for each uh area
a slide that we're prepared to discuss
for those top three
and our first one is the um
good afternoon david weeders information
services director dhhs
so the third on the third slide the
statewide child welfare
information system replacement we're in
our
third
third year of a six-year project
actually moving into the last biennium
so this budget
request for the capital budget is for
the last biennium of six years
and it's for eleven million two hundred
seventy thousand eight hundred dollars
half of which are general funds and the
other half are federal funds
we work with the administration for
children youth and families for that
federal fund match
this system has been
working towards a sales force
replacement of a 23 year old
power builder application
that system was required by acf or
administration for children and families
to be replaced with a comprehensive
child welfare information system
the current system named bridges or
saqquis
is
performing the necessary functions
however on the old
software it has limited itself for
the effectiveness in a mobile community
the effectiveness for our caseworkers to
be able to go out and work with their
their cases in the field as opposed to
having to come back to the office to do
work
this new system will allow for the
intake
assessment and case management both
in the office as well as in the field
eliminating
a lot of the productivity loss and
allowing for the current workforce to
deploy the services in a more effective
way
i'll stop there in case you have any
questions
okay
moving on to the fourth slide this is
the new hampshire health facilities
electronic health records system
so currently we have new hampshire
hospital that is running on an
electronic health record system with the
acquisition of hampstead hospital and
the plan implementation of a forensic
hospital we are looking to
combine efforts and deploy a single
electronic health record system across
all three facilities and potentially
additional facilities as needed
this will
allow for
the
effective diagnosis treatment and
services to interact with patients in a
point of care or
situation as well as
eliminate
duplicative efforts of the acquisition
of hampstead hospital they currently do
not have an electronic health record
system
and our goal is to expand and move that
move that direction so we're not doing
multiple ehrs
which would cost about the same amount
of money if not more if we had to do it
and this system is gonna is is looking
at nineteen million five hundred and
fifty thousand dollars of which
we have thirteen million six hundred and
eighty five thousand of general funds
and five million eight hundred and sixty
five thousand dollars of federal funds
to implement this solution over the next
biennium
and the
fifth slide we have our elderly adult
services system modernization
this one we had submitted in the past
for
for biennium budgeting for capital
projects and
due to prioritization we moved forward
on several other projects this biennium
and we're looking to move this one
forward
in the next biennium this system manages
our adult protective services on social
worker caseloads and is again gold at
leveraging the salesforce platform
and you'll see a common theme is we're
gold at using salesforce to reduce our
licensing costs across multiple
different platforms doing very similar
functionality
however the reason why we have different
capital submissions is each
area has different requirements to be
managed different workflows and
different customizations that are
required leveraging that same platform
this will automate our tasks to allow
for increased calls
as well as increased investigations
without requesting additional staffing
to do those additional services
the total amount is six million seven
hundred ninety five thousand four
hundred and twenty seven dollars
of which four million seventy seven
thousand fifty 256 is general funds and
then the remaining two million seven
hundred and eighteen thousand one
hundred seventy one is federal funds
and that was associated with working
through multiple sales force
implementations as well as
requests for information to get an idea
of the cost for both salesforce
licensing and professional services to
implement
i'm going to go ahead and turn it back
over to nathan to go over our summary
side
thank you dude
um on the last slide is the summary
slide again the the total fund request
here is approximately 37.6 million
dollars um comprising of 23.4 general
funds
and 14.2 million in federal funds from a
percentage split that's roughly 62
percent general funds and 38 federal
and uh
good afternoon again a
question on the
electronic health records i don't know
if you could take a minute and just
explain the system you currently have
that you're currently using
and
how and why that needs to be replaced
good morning uh joe christie cfo for new
hampshire hospital
hi i'm ellen lapoint i'm the ceo at new
so we currently have netsmart um avatar
as our ehr
it is a product that we struggle with
it
isn't something that is very user
friendly
and it takes a lot of
rework and support for us to be able to
do what we need to do on a daily basis
in regards to patient care we several
times
in recent history have had to go back to
netsmart and avatar and ask for changes
with the product and
different support that we need to be
able to make it user friendly whether it
be in different reports that we need to
be able to operate the hospital or
whether it be in daily function
you know on a routine basis for patient
care so it's somewhat of an antiquated
system
and we do struggle with its operation
pretty routinely when was that system
purchased the one you currently are
using
the systems like that have a have a
useful life and is that the case here
where the useful life has been
expired or expiring or is it more along
the lines of we have this and which may
be a mistake to have bought it and we're
looking for something to
you know get us to where we need to be i
would certainly say there's a useful
life component to this um the the system
runs on outdated information
software system technology i believe
it's java based
which is
quite outdated at this point the system
a ton of functionality out of the gate
either though so it was it was an okay
system when we bought it um and it's it
certainly aged uh itself out uh pretty
and for clarity's sake we just heard
that it was actually purchased about
as a commissioner just to comment on
that in a question for the group um
so
you know when i arrived in in 2015 the
system was partially implemented and
what i observed was that the
the folks in in new hampshire hospital
at the time had
had
i don't know that they'd fully vetted
what was required to run the business
and and so
even out of the gate we were having
challenges with the system and we
mitigated some of them on on the
operational side but it's still the same
software so
so um
so i i'm not surprised to see this on
there but um
i'm wondering is is glencliff part of
so it certainly is gold at being able to
be leveraged for glencliff however
glencliff has a
slightly different use case on how they
use an electronic health record system
so our goal is to really implement for
hampstead new hampshire hospital in the
forensics
forensic hospital with the
the uh the opportunity to expand into
glenclef and have the licensing there or
ability to purchase the licensing to do
that but our first three workflows
workloads were going to be those three
hospitals
um so you say that the it
when you deploy the system it will
accommodate two thousand users three
hundred external agencies and up to four
four health care facilities
um
i'm assuming that
exceeds
what your existing system can do right
now
that is correct so the existing system
can only support new hampshire hospital
in order to extend the netsmart our
avatar system to the other
solutions it would actually require a
major overhaul and a capital budget to
do that as well
the the other just as an added thing the
net netsmart is a product that is really
gold towards small organizations and
it's not in the
i wouldn't say it was in the enterprise
scale like cerner or epic those other
type of systems they're really designed
to be able to support multiple hospitals
whereas netsmart does a decent job of
one hospital it would have difficulty
all of these are matched with federal
funds to a certain extent
cash works just as well as a bonded cash
correct
for those
matching what i'm saying is you probably
ought to
consider at least asking for some of it
in your operating budget or from the
surplus
rather than taking about 20
percent of my math is correct of a
potential capital budget for software
thank you for the information that's
certainly something we can consider
in most cases
we have we submit on our operating
budget or the maintenance and operations
going forward but i certainly will we
can discuss that with our finance group
hey there good afternoon i believe in
the last capital budget um there was
significant funding put aside for
upgrading your medicaid system your
medicaid mmis system so i was just
wondering if that project is near
completion and how are your resources to
take on two additional i.t projects
that's a very good question so we have
multiple different teams set up both
with doit as well as dhhs to achieve
different projects like this so that the
medicaid management information system
that was had several different projects
in the last biennium approved is i would
say on its way but there it was a
five-year project um program somewhere
in year two of that year five and those
project teams would not be impacted by
the the projects that you see here today
because we have a different team for
our children youth and families and a
totally separate team for new hampshire
hospital and then a third one for the
i do have something i wanted to say
about representative graham's point
which i
you know anybody who does buildings um
shares the concern about the extent to
which they're gradually eaten up by i.t
projects
but
i think it's a statewide thing rather
than a departmental thing where we have
to we're going to figure out as a state
how we do these things because
you know
it is more and more and more expensive
all the time and and that's not that's
also true of buildings and at some point
we're gonna have to balance those things
and how exactly you balance it at the
end of the day if you're an agency
trying to run your operation
you look at it and you say well i need a
roof actually to some extent you might
not say that because you think the roof
is taken for granted and somebody else
will take care of it
and you're thinking
nobody will give me 20 million in my
operating budget to save my life so i'm
going to support in the capital budget
and because isn't that where we do big
it projects i guess it is and then the
counterpoint is should we be bonding a
six or eight year project over 20 years
well no but what's the alternative so i
think i think at some point the capital
budget people and the operating budget
people
and the legislative and the executive
probably ought to get together and
um
please um so so um
you know if this let's take the uh
uh electronic health record as an
example but um you know if we were to
fund that now we would have actually run
the system for 10 years which i would
consider a reasonable amount of time and
and perhaps more than that a lot of a
lot of our systems have successfully run
for considerably more than 10 years and
when they get to 30 years then you're
saying ah that's too long so somewhere
in between there i've been recommending
that we do initial contracts for a
decade on these big systems so that
we're not
you know because we're committing to
um you know we're committing to a vendor
tend to get lower pricing that way
versus three years and then keep going
back to the well with the executive
council after that so
so i would say that you know if you get
a decade out of it that's pretty good
now the funding methodology you know i i
wish the treasury were here to talk us
to us about bonding because i'm not sure
everything's bonded at 20 years i think
there were some shorter durations
yeah so
and so that there may actually be
um there may be a little more it may be
a little smarter than we're thinking
right now but
they they do go out
um annually for 20-year blinds for every
project
um
at one point they were trying i don't
know if they still do to say the
legislature was saying well it's only
for five years but they still went out
on the same bond issue for 20 years and
then it was an internal
um
check mark of well this one may be paid
off in five years but
we're still going out with one big
bonding issue
for
the money once a year
i think it's hard to do debt management
any other way right you you you know
they're doing they go out with a bond
offering and you know we're a little
tiny two-bit state you know remember
that like you know in a marketplace term
we're one-half of one percent of the
population in the country
and and to try to do a little bit of
this and a little bit of that
at some point the bond market looks at
it and goes oh for god's sakes just put
a bond on a market we'll bid on
something i'm not bidding on three
little things
and so that's an issue but but it's you
know with i.t that whole capex versus
opex thing is a
riddle we haven't solved yeah and i was
thinking about our comments earlier
because i was talking to you about the
big bump in the beginning with the
traditional acquisition value and you
take some of that out with the software
as a service but you still have
implementation costs
that that do exist but we have it you
know charlie was talking about deferred
maintenance we have a term in i.t called
technical debt and it's really the same
thing we're carrying a ton of that in
the state a lot of old systems that may
or may not be compliant so it's not
really a
either or it's as i think as charlie
correctly said we have to decide
where we're going to draw the line
during each biennium based on the
overall set of priorities for the state
and i know that like in the last two
biennium it's been a pretty big
difference in dollars i think it was
double this last biennium how much we
funded on the i.t side than we had prior
i actually have the history of the whole
thing i can send it to the committee if
you want for many years going back
because we were looking at that but i
you know i think it's an overall
prioritization thing yeah the way we the
the way you could do dead is is one of
two ways you could you could you could
issue it in you know have an an i.t
issue
where it's a shorter term issue that's
designed specifically to raise money for
it projects and then a longer term
one that would go out 20 years for your
buildings and things like that
but you know the
for efficiency purposes you group them
together and so long as you don't have
just i.t projects with eight year useful
life going out 20 years i mean the
market would view that very dimly
however because we
integrate
projects like buildings into that and
typically the way new hampshire does it
is they're front loaded debt
and so it's it's the principle is paid
off fairly rapidly over 20 years so as
long as the useful lives of the projects
match up with the useful lives of the
any other questions
may i just i just some of the challenges
um i just our capital budget is
obviously our needs are more than three
requests um it is challenging that
they're all i.t that doesn't mean that
we don't as charlie knows have any uh
building uh challenges as well so it's
challenging for us as an agency to sort
of make that priority and knowing that
we need these systems to do our business
and serve our clients but we also need
to take care of all of the other
maintenance which will and eventually
end up in our operating budget so either
way it's it's a challenging situation so
just want to throw that in there
okay
okay i'd like to thank everyone for
participating today and the
yes i believe so and the uh the hearing
will uh stand in recess until 9 a.m
you